believe it or not there are several gas
and oil leases being shut down right now
in the U.S and Joe Biden is getting
ripped apart because uh he's getting
slammed over it it's his administration
gas prices just hit a new all-time
record high average at four dollars and
41 cents and people are feeling it
there's also formula shortages and a
report coming out that illegal immigrant
processing centers are getting baby
formula
yeah you look shocked as soon as I said
it so so yeah it's like
these are bad so my point is the the
shuttering of oil and gas leases is not
100 on the Biden Administration but some
of it is and I think it does show bad
leadership period for whatever reason it
happened and it's just a remarkable how
many people try and say it's not Joe
Biden's fault everything's falling apart
yeah I don't care what you think in
terms of the fault regular people right
now are reeling from the economic crisis
in an election year I think November is
going to be absolutely brutal we've got
a couple other stories though young Ken
has finally stepped up and said the
people protesting at the Supreme Court
Justices homes should be arrested we
have this report about Merrick Garland
apparently he's got the FBI going after
uh parents over you know this this whole
school thing with CRT and um I believe
the report says he's lying about it so
we'll get into all that stuff
and then we have in Texas a law barring
social media companies from censoring
people was actually just reinstated so
that's going to get spicy we'll talk
about that along with Elon Musk and
joining us to discuss this is Will
Chamberlain good to be with you guys um
senior council at the internet
accountability project which fights big
Tech abuses and pushes for regulation on
big tech companies from a concerted
perspective and the article 3 project
which previously pushed for the
confirmation of Trump's judges and now
just generally opposes uh the left's
attempts to put really wacko liberals on
the court well all right fantastic I'm
Seamus Coughlin I run a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes we just uploaded a
video today called bro v Wade I think
you guys should go check that one out
you will enjoy it and over to you and hi
everyone love you uh hopefully we can
maybe Focus Less on blaming people for
this crap and work together and figure
out how to make it better that's what
I'm here for I think it's your fault
that sounds like something you would say
if it was your fault right now you have
leftists arguing that cryptocurrency is
a scam and advocating for all the
leftists to get away from it and never
buy it never buy in never support it and
Ian still like they're good people I
support them yeah I want to help them
change their message because
cryptocurrencies that don't have a
utility are intrinsically scammishly
trashy but utility brings value to the
Token you've got massively funded
special interest industrial complex
funded ngos screwing up a little guy
you're not it's like the wild west of
economy before we made a laws about the
political advocacy against crypto from
the left specifically I can't wait to
get into it tonight let's do it I just
thought uh sorry I don't want to bring
the tone down but today's news really
kind of infuriated me between the news
of the gas lease is being canceled and
this formula that Americans actually
really kind of need because parents are
being forced to drive around with five
dollar a gallon gasoline to find formula
for their children a little bit
infuriating so hopefully we can keep
keep happy before we get started head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to help support our work as a member
you'll get access to exclusive segments
of the timcast IRL podcast that go up at
11 PM we swear a lot they're not family
friendly they're uncensored and uh often
very offensive but that's the point it's
our Speakeasy it's where the adults go
in after hours you'll also be supporting
our journalists and you'll be supporting
alternative infrastructure because we
use Rumble infrastructure for our
website and we are expanding we are
getting away from these big Tech Silicon
Valley companies and we are moving over
towards alternate infrastructure so that
we can't be censored and that we can
help build a competitive ecosystem for
Tech which will allow people to have
their opinions so timcast.com and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you really like it let's read this
first story we got the Biden
Administration cancels prominent oil and
gas leases one environmentalist said the
announcement was good for the climate
which can't handle new oil and gas
development well let's get to the the
Nuance here quote
due to a lack of Industry interest in
leasing in the area the department will
not move forward the proposed Cook Inlet
OCS oil and gasly sale 258 a department
of interior spokesperson told Fox
Business however there's also the
department of interior ending two leases
for the Gulf of Mexico region because of
conflicting court rulings that impacted
work on these proposed lease sales
so I'm not going to come out here and
try and play some tribal nonsense where
it's like Joe Biden arbitrarily just
destroyed an oil and gas lease there's
actually questions about whether or not
these these companies are trying to
drill for oil but I wonder
when you get a president like Joe Biden
who actually shuts down an oil pipeline
at this time how many companies feel
safe investing tons of money in new
infrastructure that Joe Biden might turn
around and just shudder overnight
without due process just executive order
you're done why would an oil and gas
company want to go build in Alaska when
the president has already shown he will
destroy your investment this is bad
leadership
I agree with that actually I I'm not a
huge advocate of burning unlimited
fossil fuel without attempting to recup
recover the carbon but it seems like
maybe this is he's incentivizing people
to get off oil but it's like just a dumb
way to do it like I'll destroy
everything so you stop using it doesn't
make any sense to me well so you you in
in the golf instance you've got
environmentalists we just had that story
about the the Electric electrical plant
shutting down I think it was called
Taylin because they said regulations on
climate change so they're like we're
shutting down yo I'll tell you this you
think you think the baby food shortage
is bad let me just lay it out for
everybody because they're like what did
Joe Biden do to make the gas prices go
up all these fact Checkers are like it's
not true Joe Biden bans oil and gas
leases on federal lands speculation goes
up because Supply is expected to be
diminished in the U.S he just shuts down
the Keystone Pipeline how much money did
that cost to the oil industry
a lot and I'm not saying I like the oil
industry guys then all of a sudden
they're like why aren't they investing
to build new new oil drilling up in
Alaska I it's their fault we're not
getting any of this stuff done why would
anyone want to invest in the United
States energy production when Joe Biden
is shown he has complete disdain for it
you're going to lose all your money go
go build in Saudi Arabia or go build and
cutter and build that pipeline or
whatever yeah it's basically I mean it's
really childish right I mean there's
there's a reason I'm not generally like
this Russia hawk or whatever but Russia
literally did fund green energy groups
in the United States to try and push
against domestic oil production which is
kind of an obvious thing to do from
their perspective because hey that gives
them allows them to kind of corner the
market and increases demand for their
natural resources which they're
perfectly happy to draw in whatever way
they want to see fit
um and so I think yeah I mean I was
looking at some of the information I
don't know the the cancellation of these
leases was more about them like giving
up on a couple of like ones that had
some conflicted court rulings about yeah
um and there was like even Democrats I
think there was like a dim Tim Kaine was
on giving a speech about hey we really
need to increase production here I don't
know if you guys are are trying hard
enough here in the administration like I
don't know I feel I feel like we're in a
phase where it's like you've got I think
the White House probably is now because
they're so full board towards Ukrainian
to Russia they're like okay fine we'll
let the oil and gas leases run but maybe
the message hasn't trickled down to the
bureaucrats yet take a look at this AAA
gas prices
4 41. I guarantee you the Biden white
house does not like this right like
they're I like there are a lot of things
they're they're conniving they're
obnoxious but they're not complete
morons so they they do know that you
know gas prices at this level will lead
to them losing power no no I mean you
know the the dudes who are engaged in a
bank heist are not stupid but why would
you assume that they're looking out for
your best interest no they're not right
like that's I I don't assume the ever
that they're looking for their best
interests I just know we're we're six
months out in an election and the The
Joe Biden elections would be like John
Dillinger like trying to get appointed
as the head of a bank branch and people
being like I never heard of this guy he
sounds great and we're like please
please do not give this guy I'm telling
you he's going to loot the coffers and
they're like I don't know it looks
trustworthy cool name too and then all
of a sudden you know the bank is failing
and you're like I can't believe this is
happening well Joe Biden's crooked he's
always been crooked you put a crooked
guy in charge crooked things happen and
now all these people are like why is gas
higher than it's ever been yeah they try
to play the game it's not Joe Biden's
fault it is Vladimir Putin and the
unprecedented pandemic and it's like
dude if Joe Biden didn't cancel Keystone
if he didn't ban oil and gas leases on
federal lands if they weren't making the
moves they're making now my my point
I'll just summarize it with this if
Donald Trump was President he would be
like you know he'd be yelling get me the
head of these companies I want them in
here right now what's going on they're
making me look bad we need to get these
prices down and they would have a
meeting you'd hear in the press that the
Hat the CEOs of these companies are
coming to the Oval Office Donald Trump
would be like what do we got to do to
get you producing they'd say these
regulations are impeding us and he'd be
like we're getting rid of them get the
oil baby drill and the prices will be
going down and then they'd be fracking I
heard uh earthquakes have gone up
because of fracking or if you look at
like Oklahoma earthquakes where there's
like no earthquakes all of a sudden
since they started fracking you see
massive amounts of micro Quakes they're
not huge but but that's a good thing of
course earthquakes are always fantastic
what's happening is they're taking
liquid out of the earth and it's leaving
like a a craterous vacuum in there and
then the the the crust just ends up
slipping on itself well they're
injecting hydraulic fluid and they
inject weird chemicals back in I mean uh
just look on the bright side now that we
know we're creating earthquakes maybe we
can create some kind of um generator a
piezoelectric uh that's right energy
producer we'll get even more energy out
of it that's right never before you know
turning problems into Solutions in that
we are better than what we had at the
beginning is a human thing that's true I
mean it would be funny if like have you
guys ever seen those flashlights where
you you beat them and they charge yeah
show me that again you beat them oh yeah
I think I know what you're talking about
they're they have a magnet in it and
there's a copper coil and when you make
the motion it throws the magnet back and
forth which then generates a current and
will charge up the battery so all you
got to do is is that that's not positive
electricity electricity is like
molecular vibration it's free it's
friction based energy so once the
earthquake happens you have all these
magnets bouncing up and down in the
coils and you're just generating free
energy so after you get the the oil or
I'm sorry the gas the was it Shale is it
Shale oil actually is it oil
and everything's crumbling all around do
you just have the electrical generation
and you extract more energy I think
that's actually a really good idea we
should see if we can do that
yeah wow this sounds like Russian
disinformation yeah but I mean your
point earlier about the uh Russian
government sending funding towards
certain environmental groups to try to
discourage the production of oil in the
United States is so depressing and it's
just so indicative of how abysmally
easily the population of the political
system is influenced in this country by
people who understand our way of
thinking so the American government does
not really understand the way Russian
culture operates the way Russians think
think or the way that the Chinese
population thinks but they actually
understand the way we think really
really well to the point where we are
extremely easy for them to manipulate
it's like yes climate change no uh use
other people's oil yes stop making in
your own country yeah it's like but
you're still using the fossil fuels
you're still using them do they not
cause pollution if they come from Russia
it's ridiculous we need to invade Alaska
yes we I I agree
let's go we own it though yeah I'm no
I'm kidding like we invade it for oil
Invasion right let it secede and then
reinvade it I don't know yeah oh no I
think sending the troops and then you
know let's liberate Alaska doing that to
California right you let it secede you
re you invade it you occupy it you turn
it into a colony like an old school
territory no electoral votes and we've
solved most of the country these
problems yeah there was their subjects
there was a fantastic uh there's a
fantastic Babylon B headline a while ago
it was Biden gives Alaska back to Russia
so they can drill for oil there now
they're like so we can drill for oil
I do like that idea of California being
uh it's like oh no they seceded all
right take it back
it's ours now right you made an
interesting point natives they're called
Native Americans they're not native
Californians yeah oh yeah the uh that
people are there I think you mentioned
that politicians are easily swayed is
that like our political system is very
easily swayed if you understand the way
people you really need a strong leader
like Biden's not as strong he's a
weak-minded older man that seems to be
kind of disparate but if you have a
strong mind young person that can also
be dangerous because then they don't
listen you don't want someone that
doesn't listen but you need someone that
isn't swayed by nonsense or or the wind
you know yeah they're a representative
but they still have to have a strong
mind Trump was swayed by a lot of
nonsense yeah but well here's John
Bolton to your point in uh you want
someone right so you you want someone
ideally who's strong-minded and has a
solid moral compass you don't want
someone who's weak-minded with a solid
moral compass right you don't want
someone who's strong-minded with a poor
moral compass we have someone who's
weak-minded and has a poor moral compass
yeah he I mean he was a plagiarist in
1988 he had to drop out of the
presidential election because he was
found plagiarizing yeah
just like a Biden Inc by Politico and
they show you this map showing how every
time he gets appointed to some position
his brother gets rich off of it it's
like oh something like that it's like
how what a coincidence Obama puts him in
charge of Iraq and then also his
brother's getting contracts in Iraq and
I think I think it's just a good sign
that he's doing you know about him well
he's such a good guy no it makes sense I
mean their brothers are both equally
talented it's no surprise that his
brother is doing so well in the exact
same areas yeah his brother was awesome
and then I don't care if he's his
brother or not well why was his brother
the first one in the Biden family to
attend college is that true no that was
his speech he played I was like why am I
the first Biden to attend college he did
he like is hilarious because it's one
thing to plagiarize a speech as a
politician and take some sort of banal
utterance about Freedom or equality or
these things that usually come up in
political speeches he literally took
someone's background story like this
there's a British politician talking
yeah Neil kinnick yeah oh he was like
the first in his family to go to college
and they were working class and Biden
literally gives him guy's speech with a
couple details changed and people like
Echoes of Biden's 1987 plagiarism
Scandal continue to reverberate from
this is a Washington Post you mentioned
Neil kinnick how is he involved in the
plagiarism Scandal well it's that's the
that's whose speech is Biden plagiarized
right Neil kinnick was like a laborer uh
he was like a leader of the opposition
in Britain right during Margaret
Thatcher when Margaret Thatcher was
prime minister and literally kinnick had
just given these speeches as leader and
Biden's like that's a really good speech
and it's funny and after he heard Biden
plagiarized him he went come on man
and then Joe Biden was like that's a
good one yes we got an article here from
the guardian
mechanic on Biden's plagiarism scandal
in quotes and why he deserves to win
quote Joe's an honest guy this is the
guy who he plagiarized no way
are we sure Biden didn't put those words
in his mouth
September 2020 when that article came
out I bet it was just political
propaganda because the guy hated Trump
yeah yeah build back better was
plagiarized and I think it was um Boris
Johnson called him out I think right he
was like build back better that's our
thing and Joe Biden started using it
it's hilarious it's amazing yeah it's
just so come on man when I when I made
brexit happen no uh he he's hysterical
it's sad I and we laugh at it but at the
same time you sort of have to the
reality is this man is president of the
United States the actual sitting
president of the United States the thing
is you know he is not right for that
spot because when you're the VP for two
turns you run for president next that
every time that's very true he was
nowhere gone totally disinterested and
like Obama didn't want him to right
that's the thing like Obama sort of
settled on Biden but like can you call
him an F up you just just don't
underestimate his capability to screw
things up right like you don't have to
do this Joe hold on though you guys
aren't being fair Biden stepped down
because he's a humble man and then when
he saw Charlottesville happen he said I
need to run for president that's right
that's right he felt the fires within I
wonder who actually said that first yeah
that's such a ridiculous like a lesser
known Democrat who actually said that
and he was like that's pretty good man
uh it's hysterical that's so insane like
as if Joe Biden actually he saw that
happen and he's like you know what this
is a good opportunity to make my family
it'll be more money it would actually be
really funny if it was true it would be
funnier if it really was like Joe Biden
sitting in his basement like flick you
know flipping channels and then he sees
like CNN and he's like
I have to run for president and then he
like stands up and then he like shuffles
out of his you know with his in his
towel and his dog chasing as President
right like do you even think no one
thinks he's actually running the country
oh I do like sort of sort of like no
people I don't think it's his people I
think his geriatric nurse is making the
calls yeah and so it's like it's it's
like one of those old tropes where the
old man's in the bed and like the nurse
is sitting there and she's like Biden
says he wants to shut down oil leases
they're like well I guess Biden wants it
and like Pamela walks out like well
everyone trusts his nurse yeah man
no no who is uh who is who is the dude
who was whispering into the the Lord of
the
Rings
historical precedent for that that
happened you know Woodrow Wilson was
President he had a stroke when he was
negotiating Versailles and his wife
basically ran the country for the
remainder of his term wow so like Kamala
is basically Worm tongue that was the
name yeah and so Biden said they're like
and then she's like he says shut down
the Gas leases what did he say Mr
President
yeah and then Trump's someone should
make the meme then Trump Returns the
Return of the King oh my goodness do you
think will do you think that there's a
political solution to the the chaos or
do you look towards the private sector
more it's a political to what chaos
having Biden as president because yeah I
mean yes there's a political solution
everybody is President right kick him
out but how can we do you think that's
even politically possible sure I mean
not not in the short term right but like
you can
I mean you're going to have Democrats in
charge of the White House and therefore
the agencies for the next two years
there's not really any doing anything
about it until you elect a Republican
and things get better
um in terms of like a lot of these
specific problems I mean there's no I
don't know I worked for the sea studying
Institute you want to like privately
created like countries or something
compete that way not not getting them
out I'm not talking about I'm just
talking about we're in a situation where
we have no leadership I feel like
there's very very little to no
leadership in the country so what what
would be a short-term solution do you
see one political no there's no
short-term solution to like a lack of
leadership from the White House I mean
they were just gonna have to deal with
that like but we're we've got like two
and a half more years of Brezhnev or
whatever basically and then you know
we'll have a chance to actually replace
them what's Brezhnev Brezhnev was like
the Soviet leader who was very in a
similar situation to Biden where he was
just very very old very very sick
um and you know there were all these
people talking about how healthy and
vigorous he was in the in pravta right
like that was he was Notorious for you
know just like being kind of you know
Russia we had a really sclerotic decline
at that point the guys who were running
it were all the old revolutionaries who
were now really old oh well you know and
you sort of mentioned the propaganda arm
doing everything they could to make him
sound as if he was competent and in good
health and they're still doing that with
Joe Biden even though we see footage of
the man speaking and it's abundantly
clear to anyone who observes it that the
man is not in his right mind he wasn't
in his right mind during the primaries
when I went to Ohio to hang out with my
parents uh like over Christmas last year
I I was like yeah you know Joe Biden's a
mess and they were like no Joe Biden's
great and I was like yeah he's
experiencing mental cognitive decline
and they're like yeah
everyone knows it they're like there's
obvious yeah you take you just put a
video clip of him speaking 10 years ago
right 2012 like with when Obama was
President like perfectly articulate
clear smooth Cadence I wouldn't say I
mean more articulate but his gaffs then
were outrageous as well sure but he just
didn't he didn't stumble over his words
he was he had more energy it sounded
like a normal politician speaking in a
lot of ways right it doesn't sound like
that anymore no it's just four years out
of the spotlight chain he changed
drastically in those four years yeah
it's it's
um sundowning
is that what it's called when you get
older like you you start losing it your
brain in the afternoon is you're up you
know so here's this guy he wakes up in
the morning and he's like I'm ready to
get it and then you know within a few
hours like all right
yep yeah so the argument the media's
tried to make too and I don't hear this
as often because I think even they
realized how ridiculous it was but that
he just has a speech impediment this is
something weird quite frequently no I
know well that's ridiculous well I did a
cartoon about this called Joe Biden
speech therapist but basically the idea
is like a speech impediment doesn't make
you say poor kids are just as bright and
talented as white kids that's not how
speech impediments work like that's a
gaff the man says stupid things
Tourette's Maybe
I guess but is that a would you consider
that a speech impediment how is that
defined I'm not sure I guess I know but
they would say that he had a stutter
like it was his stutter that would cause
him to say these things dude that's not
how a stutter works yeah he's just a
stutter that just suddenly emerges at 78
years old you know and in addition to
you suddenly just having trouble making
sense yo people fall for this stuff I
know well and they will they'll
the stutter argument was useful because
what it allowed for them to do was
pretend like there wasn't a problem but
also call you mean for pointing out the
problem so when we acknowledge that
Biden can't speak straight in that even
in a State of the Union Address which
was the best he sounded he sounded
somewhat drunk he was slurring his words
if you point that out people could say
hey that's really mean and disrespectful
to say about the president but it's also
true it's only mean if you acknowledge
that it's true like that's not a mean
thing to say about someone if it isn't
the case I'm gonna pull up this meme
right here we have of Kamala Harris
because you know we're talking about
people falling for stupid things doesn't
mean that's going around that has to do
with the confirmation hearing of Brett
Kavanaugh kamalara says I'll repeat the
question can you think of any laws that
give the government power to make
decisions over the male body that's a
good impression that is
yeah it's conscription next also every
other law because the law governs your
corporeal form they're not like just
making laws about your soul making
decisions about the middle now this is
nuanced that she missed in the question
making a decision about what someone
can't do is a decision about the body
making a decision about what someone has
to do is very very rare and conscription
is one of them specifically for men and
their bodies and they have to be thrown
on the grenade for the sake of everybody
else and I think in in uh in a real
Invasion conscription is fine like if if
we were actually invaded and like all of
a sudden we're like ah then you know
this country has stormed the beaches and
they're killing people like okay well
then everybody rally together we're
gonna die but you know then Vietnam was
like not so good but uh anyway that's
not the point the point is people share
this
they they fall for these memes and I I
did a segment earlier because I
responded to it by just saying I'm
pro-choice I believe men and women both
have the right to choose whether or not
they are parents and that means child
support is over and they all got
triggered and I I genuinely didn't think
that you know the Liberals would would
get angry over this I thought they would
agree and be like yes people no they
were like men have no choice and no say
in the matter women get the choice
that's it and I and the reason I bring
that up is
for one there's a lot of memes they fall
for but the other thing is I think you
found a basic argument here when talking
to your your typical liberal pro-choice
person that shows they'll argue against
Choice instantly if you say those words
no more child support instantly like men
have no choice it's like oh okay I
thought you were pro-choice
no I mean they're not we've talked about
it before it's literally just them being
pro-abortion they don't care about
Choice when it comes to literally any
other issue and I said this on the show
yesterday but there really aren't other
issues that we discuss in that form so
if I say a person should be able to
choose to own a gun you don't call me
pro-choice you call me pro-gun okay well
if you're saying someone should be able
to choose to have an abortion you are
pro-abortion like they're pro-abortion
um I don't know because I'm pro-choice
when it comes to religion but I'm not
pro-religion hmm
that is an interesting point that's an
interesting point but I think if there
were people who are like trying to ban a
religion we'd probably call them
anti-religion and if you were on the
argue if you were on the side of the
debate saying that religion should be
legalized or normalized or something
they probably would call you
pro-religion and that's a hypothetical
but I'm talking about like the actual
political issues we deal with and there
really aren't other ones that we have
the discussion about where we just say
like they're in favor of choice and
don't discuss what they're talking about
choosing like even even when it comes to
educational vouchers we call it school
choice we don't just call them
pro-choice at what point can we refer to
the like the left culture War grifters
as
anti-disestablishmentarianism
as soon as we do they'll redefine it man
what's the definition I mean I think
that word specifically referred to some
like church thing it was like a British
movement to I for the
anti-disestablishment so it's like you
must have something to do with the the
Church of England but I was just
thinking like I was thinking like we're
just we're anti-establishment people we
like we oppose the establishment
institutions and so these people oppose
the people who are anti so it's
anti-anti establishment yeah they want
they want to come together they want
anti-disestablishmentarians and project
that they would say like well actually
you're on the side of the establishment
we're against these thousands that's why
every fast food company in the country
has the same opinions as me right that's
why we we're we work for Jeff bezos's
company did you guys see that there was
an op-ed in the Washington Post arguing
for George Washington University to
change its name I did see that like the
Washington Post right above it and I'm
just like you know we can all sit here
and laugh about it but it's kind of like
you know with the with the gas prices
story and the oil and gas leases
we're on the we're on a big boat let's
hit an iceberg
and as it's sinking there are a bunch of
people claiming it's not really sinking
and you're stupid and it's a good or
that's a good thing that it's sinking
meanwhile the the captain and his crew
are looting the silverware and jumping
into lifeboats sending all of their
valuables to another boat and we're
sitting here yelling like they're all
but we're all trapped on this boat
they're also finding some people on the
boat though here here's some silverware
go tell everyone else that everything's
fine so then the person's like thanks
for the silverware they go back onto the
boat and they're like hey guys I guess
everything's fine and then as by the
time they come back the dude's gone with
all the rest of the silverware like
they're bribing people to lie to us
right now is the question
that Kamala Harris when she asks a
question like this is she really dumb or
is she conniving oh she's connected I
think it's both maybe both I think it's
both so I think she's conniving I think
she's intelligent in the way she
connives in some respects but on this
issue I think she's actually probably
just dumb I would not be surprised if
she hasn't questioned this particular
perspective and yeah if you had said
responded in lockstep conscription she
was just been nodded in stunned silence
can I just point out that there are a
lot of laws prohibiting men from doing
specific things with their bodies in
public gross things yes like uh any laws
that give the government power to make
decisions about the male body
yes
we should get into it on the after show
yeah
well no but
like I said every single law governs
your corporeal form like they're not
making laws about what you can do with
your soul they're like they're making
loss about what you do with your body
look at this get this they're not going
to convict you when I when I respond to
this meme by saying that I was
pro-choice and that men should choose to
be able to you know like Dave Chappelle
made that joke he's like you can if you
can choose to kill it I can choose to at
least abandon it and that everyone left
and I kid you not the responses I got
were the man made a choice
and he got a woman pregnant and now it's
his responsibility he can't just claim
and I was like wait a minute what
they're saying is all women are raped
like every Act of sex is actually rape
because they're never consent to sex
they're saying but I mean like literally
they're saying women get a choice and
men don't what if for the exact same
reasons but they were making pro-life
arguments as to why men don't get a
choice and I'm just like
what are they just anti-men
like if I was like if you make a
pro-choice argument and I agree with you
but then you just all of a sudden give
me the pro-life version of it he he made
a choice and he could have used birth
control I kid you not they said condoms
and birth control are readily available
it's his fault he has to be responsible
for it and I'm like are you are you what
we talked about this we talked about
this yesterday at some point even if
they don't do so in in the totality of
the position at some point left Wingers
come back around to a right-wing
position they get so far to the left so
the other day I was joking that they'll
say things like well if abortion's
illegal then men should be forced to
take care of the children they're like
yes every conservative agrees with that
and on this point when you when you talk
about uh men and child support all of a
sudden they're very big fans of personal
responsibility and not having sex with
someone you wouldn't have a child with
there was a a bill in Florida to ban
abortion for 15 weeks so a Democrat
proposed an amendment that would require
men to pay child support at 15 weeks and
then I was just like awesome yeah I
don't understand you know can the
pro-life people want marriage they don't
want they want child support from
conception yeah also they want familial
support before concession also like what
kind of insane Society do we live in
where the political solution is oh like
let's legislate that someone should have
to pay for his pregnant woman's unborn
child like there used to be a social
mechanism for that right people would
get married and have kids and a man
would be ashamed if he was not taking
care of the child that he had created
with a woman cultural enforcement and
cultural Decay there you have to
legislate things that Society doesn't do
so people aren't supporting their kids
and you're like okay we gotta we got we
have to tell them they have to culture
used to have you know as what uh Jordan
Peterson called cultural and enforcement
organization enforcement and then just
like every other circumstance where the
left has no idea what's going on they
assume what it means without asking
questions or doing any basic research
and then they're like Jordan Peterson
wants to force women to marry literally
not what he's talking about no actually
I I do yeah no I mean if I see you
outside you can hop over real quick
everybody let's go to chicken City oh
maybe I just saw a buffered thing I
think they buffered 15 seconds when I
click on a stream let me see if it keeps
going
technical glitches the segment where the
stream goes down it was unbelievable I
wonder why this is happening it's
Sheamus's fault probably it's probably
because will Chamberlain's here because
I've been on the show a lot of times and
it hasn't Frozen but he's here
uh I don't remember I remember it did
freeze on Ian Garden that's right yeah I
was a poso I remember yeah I think it
was can we take this opportunity to
swear our brain no no no no no
keep talking yeah the show going we'll
be we'll be uploading this to rumble
Rumble yeah we should upload this one to
rumble because yeah it's a good idea
pretty junked yeah well I'm gonna upload
the whole episode to all podcast
platforms and I'll use the raw file to
make Clips cool how's family life well
oh yeah they just came back
we're back did you hear my question so
yeah I wonder how much of that dropped
off yeah
all you know Sheamus saying all like his
bank personal information yeah
honestly dude I've never had a gaffe
like that before so so uh everybody
everybody that was YouTube Not Us yeah
not us yeah our internet is completely
fine and I believe chicken City never
went down that's right so you could have
been there we we use the same internet
feed for a couple different things and
we had so this was a YouTube thing
there were other streams that were also
I checked zuby's live stream and that
was also paused and it's still paused
yeah it's going on yeah YouTube's under
attack YouTuber
you got a story from the daily mail this
is what America looks America last looks
like GOP rep fumes at pallets of baby
formula being sent to border centers for
illegal migrants while American babies
go without a mid Nationwide shortage so
she posts this picture she said she got
from a border uh uh Patrol agent the
first photo is from the Ursula
processing center at the U.S border
shelves packed with baby formula my
favorite thing about it you're gonna
love this is there are signs that say I
think it says like 84. let me actually I
don't know if they have you can see it
what does it say it says like 84 times
26 equals 216 2016. and people are like
it says 2016. it's clearly a very old
photograph what and it's like dude
they're talking about the amount of baby
formula they have everybody who says
this is fake doesn't have a child or has
does not purchase formula like it's it's
you know I mean but are they really
giving it to illegal immigrants I mean
I'm sure they have like a backup Supply
right like they've probably got their
supply line set up but here's the thing
to understand right there's a lot of
it's not the hardest to find like the
standard issue formula right now right
there's sort of like the very basic like
most companies that make formula and you
know have some sort of like formula that
is the default close to similar to
breast milk formula right and that's
usually that's still available in a lot
of places and even if you can't find the
brand you've been used to you can find
like a version of that the problem is
that some babies need these like very
Niche specialty formulas because they
have very special nutritional needs they
just don't all rate the normal stuff and
those babies are stuck there might be
like two companies making that
particular that particular type of
formula and they're scrambling and it's
like they can't eat anything else and I
mean there's there's people saying how's
milk right oh no you they can't they
can't eat anything else this is what
they eat yeah and goats of milk yeah
like they're they're scrambling to find
it right horse milk horse milk right
um we tried it you know so I mean this
is a this is a real thing like you know
our on our end like you know we've we
have to use formula it's not that's not
a choice we need to yeah
um and we've we're lucky that our little
Elizabeth tolerates like the standard
issue normal close to breastmil formula
so we've been able to switch but we're
about to we've already switched once
right we switched away from Similac to
like this Amazon house brand now we're
gonna have to switch away from the
Amazon house brand because that's out of
stock so we're switching into like
something else
um and you're just wondering like what's
the next thing that's going to go out of
stock right like when's the when is this
going to end and and they're going to
get this plan they shut down this like
the single most you know biggest
production baby formula plant in the
country over some health issues and they
haven't reopened it and it's like
there's there's there's problems like
we've empty shelves before well uh I
just found out that cow's milk has no
vitamin C but horse milk actually has
lots of vitamin C I'll thank you for the
suggestion good suggestion yeah well I
mean so so but I've seen a lot of posts
from uh you know we made we actually
made the joke just breastfeed and then I
can't remember who had on but they were
like what did mothers do before Nestle
it wasn't Incorporated but I understand
not everybody can or does nurses yeah
the answer is yeah wet nurses right like
unless you know that you would go down
to the town forum and there would be
women who could breastfeed and you would
hand your child over to through the
woman whose job it was to literally
breastfeed everything so women need to
create breastfeed pods if they have a
baby
I mean I I
don't know what else you're gonna do if
you're baby's starving you're going to
do what you got to do right we have the
equivalent some form of that in the LA
latte League which is women who donate
excess breast milk which is such an
amazing idea this is an international
league where you can go to almost any
Community there's one in Frederick
there's a bunch in this area and you
need to hook up with that and see if
there's women who are willing to donate
because some of them have extra so I
think that's probably the best source
for people who are really struggling to
find Formula pediatricians say not to
make it but I also know that
pediatricians get a lot of kickbacks
from these companies to recommend these
formulas if you think a person can live
off of nothing but human breast milk uh
probably not an adult probably not an
adult yeah it doesn't bodybuilders buy
it yeah but they're dumb I don't know
it's it's but yeah I mean there's people
who are like and then that doesn't Serve
Yourself they're like some babies who
can't tolerate breast milk they really
do need very specific things well I mean
but let's be real will you know I don't
think your child is deserving of it
because there are oppressed marginalized
babies right right there was somebody
who tweeted would you consider that I
deserve it well we tweeted out that I
was well stocked on formula right
because like we I've seen this coming
this has been in the news so you know we
got like maybe two months of formula in
the just in the pantry and somebody
somebody you know tweeted me it's like
what about other people's babies you're
being selfish like do you do you think
your child is more important than other
people's children I was like yes I do
care to me yes other people's children
are other people's job my child is my
job I just love that question do you
think your kids are more important yeah
yes of course
yeah no I mean look it's a serious
problem we can talk about all the other
inflationary pressures people are facing
but a shortage of formula for the
families who really need I mean that is
devastating that is I mean it's like the
only food like imagine going to the
grocery store and there's nothing there
now so that's the equivalent for these
children who like can eat one thing and
that's their entire diet now hold on
hold on that's an unbelievable scale
yeah we got these photos right here's a
photo from the store of the empty baby
formula section explain to those who
don't understand it looks like there is
Formula what's the parents just buy
these formulas so first off it means you
have to switch right like no matter what
so like there's there's only one brand
that actually has canisters right that's
the it looks like Enfamil which is on
the top row then you have like that
means so if you're if your kid is used
to and tolerates some other formula like
Similac which is the other major brand
or like the house Brands like you don't
really like switching formula because
your baby tolerates and it works you
want to stick with the same one
um but that so basically it means like
it doesn't matter if you've been using
Similac or any other brand guess what
the only thing available today is
Enfamil and over moreover not all the
infamous up there so if your baby
tolerates a very specific like kind of
skin type of formula say one that's like
lactose free for sensitive or some you
know there's there's Alimentum there's a
wide variety well that might not be
there so guess what the the formula your
baby tolerates isn't at the store so you
need to go to another store
um you need to drive and moreover it's
like you know there's there's not that
much on the shelf right there right like
you know the the Similac thing that
little the the bottle that's like
nothing because the powder is actually
where you actually can feed your kid in
bulk right like most the way most people
end up making formulas you have you get
the powder in bulk you add water and you
mix it and so like one canister powder
will last you like a week right that
little like thing that the bottle on the
middle shelf right that'll last you
uh eight you know 12 hours right that's
like 12 hours of food we gotta make wet
nurses great again right like apparently
so that's that that's a serious that's a
problem right like it's not that you
know most babies will probably be able
to tolerate one of the formulas that's
on the top shelf but that's not good and
it really needs to not get worse right
and then for some babies that's a huge
problem I'm wondering like how often do
uh do societies go through this period
where there's like this fall off you
know what I mean a Strife I I suppose we
can make references to stress out
generational theory of the fourth
turning or whatever but I'm wondering
you know
all of a sudden we had this luxury that
is that is Formula we used to need wet
nurses that was the normal human thing
we invented formula we invented a
process by which we could feed babies
and now all of a sudden it's a shock to
our system that we don't have it if we
were still doing traditional wetner
stuff nobody would be nobody would care
about this so it seems like the
developments and everything we've had
being ripped away gas prices through the
roof you can't drive anymore it's hard
to work it's hard to buy a house food
shortages diesel shortages baby formula
shortages cat food shortages it's like
we reached this plateau of luxury and
now we're being dropped off and like I'm
wondering does that happen often it
seems like it's part of the system of
growth because I was thinking last night
like what if I just disposed of my feces
in the woods I'd be like well be
wouldn't be a problem as a one-off like
I could do it one time but it's not
sustainable and as the city grows people
not everyone can just go dump their
waste in the woods and I think they
should throw out their Windows yeah
exactly when you have a few enough
people it's fine just send it over there
over the hill over there and you have to
think about it but you know once the
Society grows to a point you can't like
wet nurses maybe you could argue the wet
nurses no longer made sense I think in
this Society they could mandatory
milking wet nurses I mean it's it's not
economical right like you you know as
opposed to paying it in terms of
I mean but the thing is it's not fragile
yeah I'll tell you this right now I'm
willing to bet women who are
overproducing are are making a good
penny oh I'm sure they are because that
you've already had women who sell their
breast milk to bodybuilders and I guess
the idea is they're like human breast
milk is formulated perfectly for humans
so bodybuilders buy it and they're like
you know they want it but you also have
mothers who buy it when they when they
can't produce because they prefer breast
milk over formula I think the demand the
demand is obviously through the roof so
you know we joke about wet nurses but
it's it's probably in full swing right
now it is happening could well be yeah
well I don't know isn't it interesting
that this new development and don't get
me wrong I love science I think that
scientific advances are amazing and part
of the reason we require formula is
because we're able to deliver and
sustain babies as young as 21 weeks but
it is very interesting that this
scientific development is pushing us
away from other people it is keeping us
from lot relying on somebody like a wet
nurse and of course you want to be tied
to another person but it's dissolving
the community that's the answer tied to
the the other person right no more
removal of umbilical cords until that's
right I agree absolutely you don't gotta
worry about formula the baby is just
placenta eats the cheeseburger and the
baby grows yes I can speak like formula
is a wonderful invention there's a lot
of people who rely on it for a reason uh
you know like the in terms of you know
reliably I mean because like you know
breastfeeding is not for everybody right
like it can be in a real real struggle
for people for us we absolutely needed
to switch to formula like it wasn't it
wasn't really an option by the time like
we were we made that decision for sure I
just mean you know I ask what does that
mean for our civilization if planes for
instance all of a sudden the cost of
flying is getting really really
difficult it's going up for a lot of
people what happens when these
inventions these uh these standards that
you know we'd call them luxuries 100
years ago they become standards what
happens when we lose those are we in for
a long fall we're talking about
electricity maybe the central electric
grid we're so used to that if that goes
out yeah it's like a Jenga Tower if you
take out the wrong block at the wrong
time
well you're seeing the blocks of diesel
because when with diesel going up diesel
is how we get all of the products that
go on our store shelves and you pull out
one pin and I don't think that people
understand this because we've lived such
fluffy protected lives for so long now
and I remember there was a point in time
where you could watch anything on your
computer you could order anything
through doordash and you could go to the
store and get everything and I remember
thinking this is amazing we're
incredibly lucky it's all about to fall
down and I don't remember why I thought
that but pretty soon after that we ended
up with covid started to have supply
chain disruption and I'm starting to
think that was the peak I don't know if
it's all downhill for uh for us or not
but it's not looking good and I think
it's only gonna get worse Tim you asked
earlier about our society and how if it
frequently happens like this kind of
this kind of cycle or this kind of thing
and it's like yeah we can think of
America as a society but realistically
the globe is a society the entire
species of society and starvation and
famine is prevalent in the 1900s you not
only have the hold of more which is
human cause you've got the cultural
revolution in China which I don't know
how many millions of people died from
starvation because of that and right
today we'll talk about
um over there where we're bombing in
Yemen I think that the Americans are
involved in the Saudis bombing Yemen
yeah
so like famine it's all it's almost
always there and if you're on the wrong
end of the stick
hopefully you know how to fast let's
talk about this while we're dealing with
these formula shortages and Will was
able to accurately articulate you know
the problem that people people parents
are facing with this shortage let's talk
about additional Ukraine supplemental
Appropriations act 40 billion dollars
going to Easter a war in Eastern Europe
to Aid a country that is not a not a
NATO Ally not an EU member state but for
some reason we should send one of the
largest War packages in history you know
what really freaks me out is this right
here
I mean isn't this a little effing odd
that's what I said every single Democrat
yay not a single no not a single one of
them Republicans it's like two to one
it's almost like they're gonna get
kickbacks from this or they just hate
the people they claim to represent they
have no concern for protecting their own
countrymen they don't have any desire to
ensure that the people back home have
any kind of relief it's all about
ensuring that other people imagine being
like an anti-war Democrat voter like
like someone who still believes what
Democrats believed I don't know a decade
ago on war you know it just
I'd be I'd be depressed if I were with
him like I think Lynn Greenwell did it I
mean the whole Squad voted for all this
crap the entirety of course look at this
look at this okay so here it is
you I guarantee people who are listening
can name those who voted no right I'm
gonna guess Tom Thomas Massey yes well
look Thomas Massey is right here as a
nay for of course you've got uh Marjorie
Taylor green of course where's uh where
where's she at she's in here somewhere
um Lauren bobert of course right there
saying no cawthorne's saying no mm-hmm
uh Jim Jordan says no yeah there's David
cawthorne Madison cawthorne where's he
at
I guess David cawthorne would be Madison
Kaufman because it is the same district
not an nc-11 oh okay oh is that a middle
name or something oh yeah first name
maybe I don't know well how about that
clay Higgins John Rose Ronnie Jackson
Pete Sessions
Madison Catherine his name is David
Madison cawthorne that's disingenuous
that they put him up there as David and
he goes by Madison that's really messed
up it was weird yeah I don't know
Marjorie green of course she's right
there now I just I just loved this when
I saw Glenn Greenwald tweet about it
he's like Alexandria ocasio-cortez
supporting one of the largest War
packages ever it's like there she is
well and look every single time every
single time the government fails to meet
the needs of the American people in some
significant way the response from the
left is if we didn't have such an
astronomical defense budget we could
afford to take care of people right now
and in the midst of all these problems
they go you know what let's just uh send
40 billion dollars over here to get
involved in foreign affairs here's what
I love though we have this clip from
Bill mod it's been going viral student
loan forgiveness is a loser issue for
the party that wants to win back the
working class and Bill makes a couple
good points he's like 13 percent of
Americans have student loan debt that's
not a lot of people
fifty percent of that debt is held by
graduate degrees and he was like come on
yeah he's like these are people who are
like I don't know what else to do I'm
going to keep going to school because
someone else is paying for it
Bill Maher saying that and then they all
basically agree
and so for me this was actually a
convincing argument I've often said
then I think we should forgive the uh
interest rates if you borrowed it you
got to pay it back but the interest
rates I can understand are insane after
watching this Bill Maher segment I'm
like nope never mind I'm done nah sorry
it's on you 13 and half of its graduate
degrees this is what the Democrats are
focused on the highest income earners
who want a freebie that's what it is
sorry I'm done they're just giving
something to their voters they're voters
of the professional class right like
that's that's that's 13 of people
they're going to win over I'm willing to
tolerate loan forgiveness if we classify
the debt as odious and then go at the
universities to get the payment back
right like that's you know I'm willing
to use that because there you know there
are people who like were genuinely
exploited by these universities and they
got degrees that are worthless and like
maybe don't need to be completely
miserated forever I'm cool with that but
that means that in the foreign policy
context whenever we forgive somebody
else's debt what we're saying is that's
odious debt it should never have been
issued it was wrong to issue it and we
need and we need to go back and get
essentially like
you know go back and get a reimbursement
I forget the exact word what's a
historical example of an odious debt uh
debt we would give to like an African
country under a dictator that we'd later
forgive
um you know because the new government
took power what do you think about usury
and which is basically collecting
interest on loans well I mean the the
general concept of collecting interstan
loans is I mean I think one inevitable
and two good because uh otherwise
there's never any loans right you know
and money yeah they used to be the way
that there was no interest and then it
was called usury and it was punishable
by death if someone did that and then
all of a sudden at some point in the
banking industry 1700s with Ann shell
Rothschild or something they just
started maybe wait for that you know
loans are very very old right like
you're talking you know if you're
talking loans I don't even know how old
but dead debt is I mean actually you
know people think barter is like the
original transaction that's wrong debt
is uh yeah favors favors right like
that's the basis for how uh Insurance
used to be if my house burns down I'll
owe you one and so then if your house
burns down I'll like if my house burns
down and you help me in any way I am
indebted to you and it's the inspection
the the expectation that I would then go
and help you in the event of something
similar or repay the favor usually to
clarify as unethical practice of
originating alone with an unreasonably
High interest rate
my concern is you've got Democrats who
are in lockstep voting for war and I
think the reason they do it is they know
their voters don't care about it I don't
think AOC ever was anti-war at all I
think she assumed her base cared about
it now that the media narrative is yay
Ukraine they're like okay good now we
can vote for war that's it so when I
hear about this uh debt forgiveness
stuff I'm like
y'all want 40 billion dollars for war in
Ukraine you got it the rest of your debt
sorry no dice you got your War you got
your funding you sent the money that
would have paid off your debts to
Raytheon I hope you're happy
congratulations to 344
yeah no I mean certainly there should be
no talk of of student debt forgiveness
now right like from the allowing
Republicans like the idea that they'd
allow any of this to go through from
Democrats that they wouldn't
um inflict massive punitary measures
right like I've heard Biden's thinking
about doing it unilaterally if that were
done then the next time Republicans take
power they should just simply end the
Student Loan program right like we don't
absolutely there's no jubilees it's like
protect and you're protecting your
voters from the Biden in the
professional class just basically
looting them right like because you know
the Trump the Republican voters like
that's not the professional class and so
basically like the whole student loan
death we're gonna says screw over
Republican voters to benefit Democrat
voters like we should never tolerate
that no absolutely not and this sort of
goes back to a conversation we've had a
number of times on this show about the
moral foundations and the fact that the
two moral foundations that people on the
left have are care and fairness and
those two values by themselves not
tempered by other values literally don't
mean anything right so if you're talking
about something like loyalty we can sort
of put somewhat objective metrics on
that right I would actually say very
objective metrics with Karen fairness
the way it's articulated by the left
especially care that can literally just
mean it can literally mean anything like
we have to care about other people we
have to help other people and you don't
have to give a robust argument for why
what you're doing actually will help and
how it won't be of too much negative
consequence to the people who the help
is coming at the expense of right and
they certainly don't and that produces
not only examples like uh so many
senators on the left or I'm sorry so
many political leaders on the left who
have argued against War sending money to
Ukraine
it's also a huge part of the reason why
we had a 4.2 trillion dollar bailout and
added an insane percentage of currency
to the money supply over the course of
two years and have runaway inflation as
a result because no one considers the
negative long-term effects of Any Given
policy prescription because all they
have to say is see look at me I care
look at me I'm doing the thing that's
fair for people what do you think would
happen if red areas stopped trading with
blue areas like I don't mean State I
mean areas rural Illinois was just like
we're no longer going to be doing
business with the city well if Rural
Maryland decided to stop sending stuff
to Baltimore I don't know what would
happen it'd be a mess wouldn't be good I
mean this is where a lot of this stuff
comes from we create a lot of farms
around here a lot of cows a lot of grain
I I wonder what value rural Falk get
from city Folk and obviously there's
like technology advancements there's
insurance companies there's media and
stuff but we're getting so divided at
this point and so many people are are
content with I mean we're facing
decentralization of of the economy
cultural Development A lot of these jobs
can be done outside of cities what is
the benefit for any any conservative to
do business inside of a city or with
cities when they can distribute via the
Internet or through shipping or whatever
uh personally I haven't been to a city
in like a long time many many months
many many months you end up needing
certain things certain professional
class Services right and you think about
Legal Services you end up needing uh
Medical Services we got lawyers out here
yeah we do I mean you do but like it can
get
I don't know it depends like
there's a reason that like these these
City you know metropolises open up and I
mean you think about a place like
Chicago what is Chicago built around
well it's the Hub of the entire Midwest
you know the agriculture uh like that's
where the Commodities markets are but I
mean I understand why back in the day
sure centralization was important so you
run a big farm
you set up your headquarters in Chicago
because you can walk 10 feet and there's
the headquarters of another company that
you need to trade with well now we're
doing everything online well yeah I was
just thinking I did spend time in
Nashville at very centralized uh active
music scene and it's kind of like why do
we use Twitter when it's we know it's
crap because it's centralized and that's
where everyone's at same with Nashville
I go there because that's where they
live so there's this idea that wealth
disappears within three generations when
it's inherited and I almost wonder if
we're asking the same question about
many of these large cities in the sense
that have they given the world something
tremendous in order to start themselves
it becomes centers of wealth and are
they now more or less squandering that
wealth by doing jobs which are more or
less useless and unnecessary because of
their position within Society because
that's often how wealth leaves a family
right the people are insulated from the
realities of what not being productive
results in so they like stop being
productive and eventually lose all their
money that's the story of Detroit right
like that's actually a very I mean we we
don't it's hard for us to understand but
Detroit used to be like the
up-and-coming economic center of the
country the third biggest you know City
you know and like one of the you know I
mean Detroit shrunk massively but when
you know in the car Heyday of the car
industry pre-silican Valley like Detroit
was the place to go if you were a young
person you know the economic engine of
the country the Silicon Valley of its
time and now it's not
um you know there's I think there's a
natural life cycle to these things you
know you have some wildly profitable
powerful Innovative industry in your
economic area it allows the government
to get away with all sorts of
shenanigans and still have you know the
place function pretty well
um but if that industry declines Things
Fall Apart really quick I was uh looking
at Rogan's Instagram Joe Rogan and uh he
reposted this thing from Tim Oliphant an
artist who's an incredible artist
incredible artist of Elon Jones of chimp
flying the ship that they're in the
Tesla ship spaceship and but it made me
very sad because what Tim was saying is
that
I've drawn since I was a kid graduated
from college with an art degree a few
years later I found myself pursuing in a
miserable Home Improvement job mostly
painting houses but Joe inspired him to
quit his home improvement job and become
a full-time artist and I was like uh
this is where our society has done to
people people don't want to do home
improvement work they don't want to be
plumbers they want to be artists and
this is a big problem a functional job
that has has great benefit to society
that is tangible and people are like but
I don't want to service my community I
want to draw pictures and I certainly
respect our I make art we make music but
I think the issue is not it may be
unfair to Target the one guy who's
actually a really good artist and you
know what drawing pictures isn't so bad
it can be a useful way for a person
he went on to clarify that he was he
didn't like working for a corporation
and being part of the Cog in the machine
thing I get that yeah I was gonna say I
find it remarkable that we're in this
this uh We've developed to a point where
complaining on the Internet is more
valuable than building a house or fixing
someone's Plumbing that's not the
picture it absolutely because you can't
have the same number of people doing it
like a small minority of people are able
to become very successful doing
something like this but if it was
equally as valuable like we would have
just as many people in both trades
making money but like most people who
try to make money complaining on the
internet totally fail whereas I think if
you go to trade school you are pretty
likely to make an income it's fair point
it's fair point I just think you know
Ian you made a good point we people
should feel good about doing trades and
I just think
when we're kids or at least when I was
the millennial generation were told to
be the greatest of all time we're told
to be rock stars and race car drivers
and astronauts well yeah it's we have
denigrated work so much right there was
this idea and almost everyone was told
this growing up uh not me personally but
so many people I know had their parents
tell them things like you know if you
don't uh study hard and get that degree
you're going to end up in you know
manual labor or as a sanitary worker or
something like that
and for some people that's what they
want to do and thank goodness because
that's an extremely valuable
contribution yeah I should be very clear
about all the fun I've never talked to
Tim Oliphant before and he specified
that he didn't he he got offered his
boss's job at the at the Home
Improvement and he didn't want to climb
the ladder and I understand being part
of corporate Corporation and I get it
but you know what made me sad was just
the lack of Desire or just the
sociological lack of desire to fix
houses and more that people want to
paint pictures anytime you I mean I
that's my personal experience right like
I was a big law and and you might say
well that's a really prestigious
professional job and like I just looked
around and realized some of the cases I
was working on like okay this might not
be like literally working with my hands
or something but I am a cogney
litigation machine right like I am
representing a trust created out of a
bankruptcy of a company that is suing 64
of these small issuers out of some
mortgage-backed Securities and like
we're you know constructing these briefs
in order to extract whatever we can out
of these small little issuers to the
benefit of this bankruptcy trust which
you can literally go and buy shares in
and the only thing you know the only
thing that this trust owns is the rights
to the proceeds of the litigation you'll
always work for someone yeah there's no
difference between being the employee of
a company and running your company now
obviously there are certain differences
what I mean to say is
I have to negotiate with people I work
with all day every day you know we've
got a bunch of people that are involved
in how this company works from the
infrastructure end of things to the ad
sales end of things and their
disagreements and there are term
deal terminations
now if you have a simple agreement with
another person I'll do this work for you
in exchange for this rate that's the
exact same thing we do that I do every
day as someone who owns the company
I just I think people need to get out of
the mindset of I'm a cog in a machine
working for someone no
you provide a service you negotiate with
company if companies not providing you
what you need you leave and negotiate
with someone else when I worked for vice
people were shocked that I quit when I
quit and they were like why would you
leave Vice is the best oh they're the
greatest and I was like Vice works for
me and I'll work for them when they
stopped providing me with what I needed
I fired them that that's the mentality I
had I went in there I said guys I want
this this and this you got it okay I'm
gonna do my thing I will do my thing
here you like that okay Greg you got to
give me these things for it I didn't
just go and say I need a paycheck I said
I want these three things delivered to
me in exchange for what you're going to
get and I worked for them as an employee
and then once they stopped delivering or
didn't provide I just said
I'm out I think of it as an employee
you're working for the corporation so is
the owner of the corporation you're both
working for the betterment of the
corporation and the owner primarily is
working for the people that are buying
his goods and services or her goods and
services the problem is when employees
don't have incentive to they don't gain
more if the company gains more and the
owner gains more so
that I understand feeling like a cog
because you're not getting an incentive
some work some work is just more
intellectually stimulating than other
work and interesting intrinsically like
I don't know there's I can I can see how
a guy would you know want to be an
artist and would get more value and
excitement out of doing art and seeing
it spread around the world than they
would out of you know I think it's I
think it's a mix of cultural and uh
human nature humans want social
acceptance we want other people to
praise us and say we're doing good
things it works really well in a small
tribal scale when you are in a village
of 50 people and you do something you
come back with a huge bore and
everyone's clapping and cheering because
they're happy because they're going to
eat and you did this great thing it
feels really good and it's how grooming
Works online in these schools they keep
trying to shower you with love and make
you feel good because humans crave
social acceptance because we're social
creatures so what ends up happening is
over time you will get more praise for
writing a good song than you will
you know uh saving someone from a
burning building depending on the scale
of the burning building I suppose like
if you're a guy who's like in a plane
and you crash into the Hudson River or
whatever you'll be here on the butcher
magazine but how many firefighters are
you know walking the red carpet how many
police officers I just watched this
crazy viral video of a cop walks right
up to a to arrest a guy and the guy just
unloads on him and then like it's brutal
footage of stuff with this thing how
often do we have no cops are demonized
to an insane degree like I certainly
have my complaints about
authoritarianism and what the police
department that can mean in terms of
certain circumstances but we demonize
the people who are working the
day-to-day jobs to make the system run
to save lives
you you'll get some 20 year old who will
spend 15 minutes writing a song and I
literally mean 15 minutes they'll be
like okay we got the beat we got the
hook we got the chorus send it over to a
company who then says we're going to
layer get it done and then they're like
put it on TV for us and all of a sudden
everyone's screaming and crying and
clapping and cheering you are the
greatest
why would someone strive to be a
firefighter there was a poll
they ask young people what they what
they wanted to be when they grew up and
you know they all said in America
influencers and you know they all said
in China
astronauts like yep so we have a
cultural problem where our culture
Praises influencer because it's simple
virality is a machine in which we get
people addicted and it feels good to get
those numbers to see that that number
going up to see those views YouTubers
have long talked about how when their
viewership goes down they get depressed
I can always tell you whenever you see
these YouTuber burnouts where they're
like I just can't keep doing this
anymore look at their view count
it almost always is uh preceded by their
viewers like the last five videos they
made were lower than normal and then all
of a sudden they have a breakdown
because it feels like you're losing and
everybody hates you and it's being
ripped apart ripped away from you
meanwhile in China they're like I really
want to be an astronaut
we need to bring that back well in in we
in some ways we become more like the
things that we love and our culture has
lost sight of of what's really important
unfortunately well maybe and now now
some kudos to Tim oliphon not only are
you one of the best artists I've ever
seen Tim uh
you're inspiring people to become
astronauts man this art will do that
yeah no I mean look our has utility and
this is coming from a guy who makes
cartoons which is like you know by no
means High art and I'm very blessed I'm
very fortunate to be able to do what I
do everyone who's on my crew who helps
me is absolutely fantastic and
unbelievably talented
but one of the biggest compliments that
I receive from people is from folks who
are just working regular nine to fives
you know important jobs construction
workers plumbers Etc who will say things
like hey man your cartoon's brighten my
day I think that's awesome and I think
art can serve that purpose but very
often times what people want to do is
make it completely about themselves so
it's not about I want to enter I want to
entertain an audience it's about like I
want to get the praise I want to be the
cool person I want to be worshiped
basically and I think that Temptation
sets in with anyone anytime they're in
front of any kind of audience
and what people have to keep sight of is
you're producing for other people and
that's true in any industry it doesn't
matter what you do and so part of the
reason I think our culture doesn't take
pride in its work is because we view it
as something which should just be about
ourselves and whether you become a
literal rock star musician or whether
you're building houses if you view what
you're doing as just being about you and
not for other people you're going to be
miserable well here I'll simplify it or
I'll put my view very simply for people
I think most people most of the time if
you are driven to become famous and
successful and you think I've had people
say this to me when I was working for
advice and traveling around they'd say I
really wish I could do what you did I'd
love to travel around the world covering
these stories I know they're not serious
I know what they're really saying is I
want people watching me on on the
internet I want millions of views I want
the praise because it's really easy to
buy a plane ticket to Europe and walk
around with a cell phone in fact I you
know when I went I went to Spain and
covered a lot of the protests well I
already own the cell phones that didn't
cost me anything the plane ticket was a
couple hundred bucks I crashed you know
at a hostel for like 70 bucks uh you
know it was like 70 bucks for a couple
days and then I walked around filming
stuff
you can just do it if you want to do it
so you know how do we get started on a
show like this well I wanted to do it I
didn't I there was when we started doing
the show we were getting you know like a
thousand people watching and I wasn't I
wasn't every day going like come on get
those numbers up get those I was just
like I like talking about these things
something changed in the dynamic of
artistry when people gained the ability
to control their own distribution
channels because
radio basically in television you gained
Rich artists that never really existed
in the past you'd have people that were
basically page you'd have they'd have a
patron like Leonardo da Vinci or whoever
they might have some money but it was
usually like a very wealthy landowner
paying them money to work and then they
would be their Patron and then now all
of a sudden we've got Rockstar TV star
those didn't exist until 100 years ago
and it's messing with people they think
that it's a rich scheme be an actor to
get rich be a musician together it's not
about it was never about the money
people would play music for dinner at
night at a Tavern and hope that they got
a place to stay and that was the
original you know I mean there were
orchestras they were there were great
works but it really was like the wealthy
being like we like these things we
wanted yeah but there were individuals
residuals is a new idea you would all
you would get paid for the night that
you played and that was it and then they
developed a recording and now it's
another another realm but there were
famous musicians for a long time yeah
they would be famous but they wouldn't
always be rich that was the weird thing
until they could until they could sell
copies of their work right once once we
had um cop media all of a sudden albums
could be sold and the song could be
performed everywhere all at once and
everyone would buy it up now we have
streaming and everyone's losing money
and piracy you see the age of I don't
like it's not actual pirate har har but
it's like you know money
um art distribution copying and
distributing it illegally or or
unethically
um and and it's like it's almost like
we're coming full circle like we've
passed through the age of the rich
artist and now we're going back to like
just be an artist if you want to be an
artist and do it in addition to your
other things that you do you don't have
to only just be an artist all the time
and you can we're actually going back to
sort of old school patronage right like
except decentralized
um you know you don't own the I mean you
don't necessarily say that you own the
rights to anything but people will be
like members to your show and right have
to you know Patron you know patronize
you that way
um I think it's I mean and I think
that's probably a good thing I mean you
know it it's not as good for artists in
general if they can't you know control
their medium well enough to sell it
effectively like as a track it's
extremely good because the patron can't
dictate what the artist does now there's
so many little patrons that the artist
still has autonomy yeah which this shows
I do think we might see a shift into and
uh we're saying we're seeing the
attention economy expand right so we had
we had the manufacturing economy people
talked about will a service economy work
where people are providing Services we
gotta we got to manufacture stuff now
we're in the attention economy where
people make a living by just getting
your attention now that's scary because
people then make crazy content and crazy
videos to try and get your attention to
make money off of it so we're in the
influence space I think we're going to
move into a Creator economy so influence
I think can only go so far once everyone
has a certain degree of influence and
then I think what we're seeing with this
art what we're seeing with YouTube and
Tick Tock is a creator-based economy
where
instead of manufacturing things you're
going to make art you're going to make
entertainment you're going to make ideas
or something I think computer code is an
example of that it's a type of art that
translates into a functional object
I wonder though I mean oh no by all
means go ahead no no go ahead I I just
want to piggyback on what Tim saying
here and ask a question you sort of
mentioned a shifting into a Creator
economy but I wonder if our economy is
is gonna I mean how long is it gonna
take for it to recover to the point
where that continues to really be
pragmatic because if we really start to
struggle for resources I don't know how
we'd be able to support that
I mean you could look far ahead into
like 3D printing food and 3D printing
oil and water like um 3D printing oils
yeah if you have enough uh electricity
you could convert plastic into oil if
you have enough carbon you talk about
molecular Printing and yeah Atomic
Printing and stuff they've they've
worked on molecular printing for
medicine thus far but I imagine we'll
head towards Atomic printing but I mean
that's that just comes out of the energy
source are they going to let us use
Fusion are they going to keep acting
like it doesn't exist I don't know
I guess I'm more optimistic now that I
think about it you know and my
investments match that right like I'm
betting on the you know the general
strength of the American economy that's
how I invested that's how I'm betting
I'm not saying a Creator based economy
is gonna be a bad thing you know I I and
so what I mean by that is it it will be
very similar to an influence economy but
it'll be people making art and then just
selling it and you're not gonna need
Amazon you know you don't need to go to
stores anymore nobody needs to work at
McDonald's we got kiosks all of those
jobs are going away so the service jobs
are being automated people are gonna
have to find other things that people
want to exchange for and I think it's
going to be someone was going to write a
song they're going to make a piece of
art they're going to create things and
then that's going to be how they sell it
or they post it or nft or something like
that and there will be a way in which
people can can acquire resources in a
new kind of economy in the future art is
the new currency or one of the new
currencies it's like the old seashells
they used to find and give to their
wives ten thousand hundred thousand
years ago you know these are the new
seashells these art pieces well let me
make everything a little bit more
pessimistic for you will that's why I
said 27. not only are diesel prices at a
new record high but they're actually
predicting diesel shortages
so
I'd like to imagine that we're headed
towards a future where we have this you
know One Step Closer towards Utopia
poverty is being eliminated but if
there's no diesel nothing's being sent
to your house your local grocery store
is going to have no meat and you better
start figuring out what you would do in
a circumstance so what is the reason
behind the diesel storage I'm actually
curious it's today that's the thesis of
the article but I want to know why I I
think it's just uh they say to drop in
production
drop in production increase demand in a
drop in production they're saying a
shortage may be next and I think Joe
Biden said we don't got enough truckers
man you know it's like someone already
super chatted us and we'll read it a bit
they said that the cost of fuel is
greater than what they make so they quit
oh boy right well okay scarcity of an
important commodity I guess that's not
good but I mean I'm still you know you
there's still a good reason to be
generally optimistic about the US
economy in terms of like finding
Alternatives I mean the higher price one
thing gets the more people figure out a
way to use different resources or come
up with a technological innovation you
know so you're not shorting it that's
what you're telling us no I'm not gonna
I'm gonna shortening the American
economy is a has been a loser's bet for
a hundred years right like that's if
you're talking about what has what has
been a bad idea shorting the American
economy
I'd say I don't I think
I think
betting on the American American economy
is the best thing you can do because in
the event the American economy collapses
and you live inside of it who cares
right oh you're in trouble I'm all in
like yeah no goals exactly like the
people who had it's sort of you know
this is kind of like the classic answer
to people who are like buying gold it's
like well why are you buying gold it's
like well the economy is going to
collapse I'm like going to you want to
buy bullets and like spam you know right
right like you know if that's if that
that's your hedge against if you're
trying to hedge against that you're not
hedging with the writers I always find
this funny when people you know Alex
Jones would always talk about buying
gold and stuff and then I was like what
am I gonna do with gold in an apocalypse
yeah am I gonna be walking down the
street and some guy's gonna have like a
sandwich and I'll give you a gold for it
I'll be like I don't want to carry that
it's heavy you can make batteries we can
make a grill sure sure you're gonna make
a batter there's gonna be a guy and he's
gonna have he's gonna have a wild Born
and you're gonna say I have a raw piece
of gold you can make a battery with it's
gonna go that's a good point I will give
you no your Baghdad battery I was
talking about if you were walking down
the street in the apocalypse and a guy
on the left has has a bottle of water
and the guy on the right has food or I
should I believe you better if if you're
walking on the street and there's a guy
with a you know a big sandwich and you
have gold and the guy next to you has a
bottle of water who do you think's
getting a piece of that sandwich yeah
yeah once basic needs are met it comes
down to the metals like copper no copper
because you make bronze with it to make
weapons Savvy weapons sometimes you can
take a water bottle is going to walk up
to the guy with the sandwich and say
I'll give you some water for some of
your sandwich in a big deal and you'll
walk up I got gold and they'll be like I
can't eat that and the other guy's gonna
be like I got this knife and you're like
ah so that's why that's where the metal
is for is weapons so it's like and
generally I think you know you don't
need to hedge that much again apocalypse
one that's extraordinarily unlikely into
you know it's the idea that you would
find the correct hedge is low well no no
it is a hedging for the apocalypse is
moving out to the middle of nowhere
getting chickens getting some yeah you
guys are doing yeah actually yeah and
you know what you're not invited now
after all this right
options no you know what Sheamus that's
well you're ridiculous no I'll build my
own car that's fine yeah
you think you think we need a cartoon
bro I'm gonna run Simpkins
I'm gonna have my own set up you're
gonna be begging to come in we don't
shimpton we don't need a cartoonist we
need a lawyer you're saying that now I
mean to be honest though like a lawyer
would probably handle negotiations
between other tribes better than like
it'd be a pretty good job Society like
figuring out your new dispute resolution
mechanisms that aren't war that seems
like that's they won't be interested man
uh I think what's gonna happen you'll go
around to other people's compounds and
be like actually we have copywritten
that method of collecting food you owe
us 10 percent yeah it would actually be
a funny bit where it's like we choose
the lawyer over the animator and the
apocalypse and then the lawyer is like
I've negotiated this really great treaty
that will benefit all of us and they're
like kill him and then the animator
walks up and he's like I drew a picture
of you and your mom together and he's
like what we're missing images of them
because if Will brings up the boring law
Sheamus can animate it make it fun for
people to understand there you go insult
their intelligent at the same time
exactly I got some some good news I
looked up how to make your own biodiesel
it's actually I don't think it's very
complicated I mean there is actually one
good Financial man like bet on the
American economy like do you think
Europe's better than us like they're not
they're they're they they have worse
rule law they have work they're way more
socialist do you think like China is
going to be a smarter bet possibly but
China's not nearly as Innovative as we
are as a general matter yeah but they
are willing to enslave people right but
then that's also like an independent
problem
like on an ethical both on a practical
and an ethical level right ethically
that's wrong but practically also that's
a recipe for instability uh yeah what's
their EKG score what is that like ESG
ESG China was worse in China no China's
gonna have a 97 or something like
America's America is still the best
place in the world to do business it's
still like has the most Innovation still
has the most like well maybe red States
it's like where is you know the problems
we're dealing with are almost like we
just
we're worried that government is going
to you know outrate essentially be so
bad that it overwhelms the benefits that
Innovation and our general economy will
bring and they're they're they're making
it closer than we want but I would still
I'd still bet on the economy I'll tell
you this New Jersey these blue states
are really destroying themselves yeah no
for real so when we when we were
headquartered in New Jersey
I was reading about you know opportunity
expansion and they said they had a
millennial brain drain Millennials uh as
soon as I shouldn't even say Milano it
was it's young people in general as soon
as they become adults they get out there
is zero opportunity and the reason for
it is they're anti-business New Jersey
is very very anti-business period so
when I was looking at expanding in new
I'm like I look you know there's an
opportunity here you got New York up
here you got Philly here you got you
know Pennsylvania right across the
street and then I was like wow those are
the laws and those are the taxes
let's leave did you ever investigate why
you think that is
it's because I think
um people on the left vote based on
their feelings and not based on what
makes sense and so they end up saying
things like hey we need more tax money
to pay for schools because more schools
and more money in schools means kids
will be better off so we need we need to
raise the taxes to get more tax money
and then what ends up happening when you
raise taxes is tax revenue goes down and
business is fully and then all of a
sudden you end up with poverty and
Corruption and broken cities and they're
like we don't understand we text the
rich it's like in the rich left what do
you think is going to happen and I mean
I mean I think competition between like
jurisdictions is different now right if
you think about who is New Jersey
competing with well they're competing
with the state of New York and the state
of Pennsylvania basically and those
states are not really super business
friendly either uh in their own right so
they probably didn't think like oh you
know we can just be a little better than
those two states and and not lose
business across the rivers New Jersey
should be one of the best states for
business and wealthiest States in the
country it's in a perfect position for
it because it's got you've you're you've
got New York right there you've got
Pennsylvania right there right so you
have a you have a real opportunity for
the people of Philly and South Jersey to
be like we do we we sell our product in
Philly but we manufacture and run our
business in Jersey because they're
better for us you've got a real
opportunity for the same thing we said
in New York we operate out of North
Jersey and then we do business in in New
York because the customers are there but
the laws are better in New Jersey they
did the opposite the first thing I was
thinking is the opposite of New Jersey
the laws are worse so nobody wants to be
there at all do you think that collude
the governments like the New York
governments like don't make your state
too much more likable than do much
better I'm sure they do yeah those state
governments work with each other right
like especially if they're the same
party like they don't really want to be
screwing each other over that much
um and you know they worked especially
think about things like coveted
regulations like they were all working
together all those like Connecticut New
York New Jersey we're like working
together to have uniform regulations so
they weren't losing people and and
honestly that's that's one of the
reasons it was more of bust there than
it was in like the DMV right the
District of Columbia tried to impose
some like really restrictive mandates
and like but they weren't in place of
Virginia and they weren't in place in
Maryland so quickly DC found out how to
get rid of them because otherwise they
would just their restaurants were empty
I wonder why Maryland you know Maryland
is a really great place you've got
Virginia West Virginia Pennsylvania and
DC and Delaware all of these different
states you could be alike come bring
your business here instead they're like
get out Maryland is really weird it is
it's a very strange case it's got to be
Delaware Delaware must have everybody on
their boot on everyone's throat like
it's the it's the state where there's
like no corporate income tax Delaware
and all every company is headquartered
in Delaware like a PO Box it's like some
one old lady
and they just they they got way ahead of
it they decided to make themselves very
favorable to business that's exactly
what they did they were nearby they were
on this Asawa you know Delaware is like
barely a state it's I mean it's
basically they make their money off of
their their corporate law like that's
their that's their industry in effect
like that's what they produce they
produce good reliable predictable
corporate law and like favorable
business favorable environment to be
incorporated I just want to ask people
did any of you actually ever look at
Delaware it's not real not real it's not
yeah it's not a real place it's like a
big City like look look at this okay
it's like they can't they don't they
don't even have access to more than they
don't even have access to half of the
peninsula they're on it's like 12 acres
it's like we're a peninsula but only
like a small part of it what what is the
other part of that Peninsula what state
is Delmarva it's yeah so both Maryland
and Virginia have a chunk of that
Peninsula so Maryland is most of it
right but then Virginia they call it the
Delmarva Peninsula huh and so Delaware
has this chunk that's it that's all they
have they couldn't even get the
peninsula they're on there's like one
city
though a lot of crab yeah great Seafood
it's just seafront property just a a
rich corporate person's dream I guess it
depends it depends on where you go
Rehoboth is very like college I mean
Wilmington Wilmington's pretty cool that
is such a weird thing really great
Seafood but uh it's it's you know what
they're I'm pretty sure they're just
funded by giving good favorable laws to
corporations and everybody's always like
what is it Delaware in Nevada or
something yeah
it's Wyoming but you know some yeah some
some states are finally starting to try
and compete for like incorporation rules
it's just now it's it's gotten to the
point where even if other states have
like a little bit better of like a
financial deal for incorporating in
their state because Delaware corporate
law is so well developed that's where
bigger companies want to be incorporated
because that's where they can get sued
so and that's where they have like the
big inter-business disputes and so
everybody's just come there's so many
more decisions so many so much their law
is just better developed and so like
that's where corporations do you know
when it began that they started making
it all about the corporation in Delaware
I don't remember exactly when it began
but I know it's you know it I don't know
yeah actually I don't know when that
began that's it but I'm sure there's
books written on it and it's it is
really sort of you know an interesting
like thing that a state like Delaware
which otherwise would not have some big
thriving business industry just really
figured out and decided ah this is what
American capitalism needs a state that
really focuses on giving corporations
what they want in terms of both like a
friendly place to incorporate and
predictable law and the people who run I
mean the lawyers they get who end up
being on like the Delaware Supreme Court
are like top tier business attorneys
like they they're super super serious
about it
um and and very very you know other
places you might get clowns and like
family members or whatever you the
Delaware Supreme Court is notorious for
having like brilliant judges everybody's
moving to Texas and I'm just like that's
such a bad idea
how come so when when big moderate types
maybe the anti-woke liberal type moves
from California or Arizona or New York
to Texas
they bring industry which is mostly full
of these Progressive left-lib you know
cultists who then come down to work
there so the obvious thing is like Joe
Rogan for instance he's a lefty dude but
we all like him he's pro-free speech and
he's he's pushed back and he's done
really great in fighting against a lot
of the the exes of the wokeness and and
the left but when he moves to Texas
he brings industry with him and large
sums of money which they're going to
hire more Hollywood producers and La
types and they're going to all flock
along with them Elon Musk is an even
better example
all of the Tesla employees from
California he's gonna have to he's gonna
have to either rehire or relocate a ton
of those California progressives into
Texas
so when I see all that happening and
Austin's already particularly woke and
everyone's like Austin's the place to be
I'm like I gotta admit Austin's really
cool
but I would not set a business there
you're you're basically saying I'm going
to sign up my business there I'm going
to move there
I'm going to invest in this city and in
five years there's a good chance I will
just be surrounded by a bunch of woke
people who have voted for this stuff
because they all followed I look at West
Virginia and I'm like West Virginia is
the second most Trump supporting state
in the country it is it is my the
country and nobody wants to be there
there's oh great so I'll go there and
it'll stay Maga country and then I will
hire people who share the values that we
have Liberty personal responsibility and
we'll create opportunity and bring
wealth to those who already agree the
thing about West Virginia for me was
it's like here's this big open place
that's real right good it's got good
laws got constitutional carry it's got
good building codes it's got good
business laws it's got uh great
incentives for new businesses and
nobody's gonna follow so that means when
we start hiring people when we start
Contracting that's people of West
Virginia who share values of personal
responsibility who are going to be
receiving that wealth not some woke
person who moved to Austin to take that
job that's that's the opportunity here
go to Florida Florida's great but I'm
like
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna set
up and expand the economy in a place
where people aren't flocking to it and
it already has the values I like yeah
there's like a I get the the image of
what I think of West Virginia I think
like walking out through Hills which is
like hurts it's exhausting and then I
picture a dude in a red hat with a gun
and I'm like well
that's that's what I when I think about
I know it's not but that's like the
liberal brainwashing
people just have this idea man I took a
walk the other day I'm close to West
Virginia right now and I went up on a
hill dude when you look around from the
top of a hill when you're out in the
middle of the in the most beautiful
areas in the world I would imagine it's
just so stunning in the air so and then
the bear comes up it heals you and be
sure you have bear spray I guess but it
was on a road so I didn't feel too just
even the drive up here was just gorgeous
today you know just driving through
rural Virginia then the bear goes up to
Ian and says it is time to prove
yourself I punch it in the face and put
my fingers down its throat oh my gosh
heavy metal place I thought about bears
what are you doing a bear comes these
days because that's like the real threat
is wild animals and I guess humans are
also animals but like you just don't let
them take your picnic basket yeah that's
right you have to stand firm you ought
to be not leave food out it's like
another lifestyle if you run he won't
respect you yeah thinking about bears
and stuff like Yogi Bear was kind of a
crazy show yeah it was still picnic
baskets but but that's all he was doing
he was like he was like a nuisance in in
the reality if you like Chase down after
a bear because you stole your picnic
basket you'd probably just Molly yours
yeah
let the picnic basket go at that point
depends on the bear I guess what do they
say for like Grizzlies you got to curl
up and cover your neck but for black
bears you gotta fight well you also have
to understand that Yogi is smarter than
the average bear and so I would assume
that means he has like some
understanding of maybe Firearms the fact
that humans can shoot him but either way
it's it's preventing him from getting
violent with people we haven't seen it
Yogi yeah we haven't seen Yogi in any of
the cartoons can you imagine because a
bear can really just destroy somebody
dude I've never seen Yogi wanted to
Ranger Rick would like be obliviated it
would just I saw Grizzly Man I highly
recommend people never see old bear
armor yeah look at this
this is Russian or something it's
probably I can't imagine that they
really wore someone like that yeah man
what what do you when you got no choice
there's a thing called the short-nosed
bear it's six days now let me see if I
can find it bear armor bear I feel like
you would still get destroyed if a bear
smacked you like it would hurt the Bear
right but they're strong one of those
things smacks you it'll blunt pretty
sure a Grizzly can hit a car door and
smack it clean off the car yeah and like
you need really large caliber rounds to
even hurt a bear
is yeah like there was a there was a
Grizzly they found I can't remember
where I was reading the story and they
finally killed it and it was riddled
with like 45 nine millimeter just
because from people shooting at it and
the ball is just like going in and doing
nothing
the Grizzlies like you could not harm me
feeble human weapons that's terrifying
um
[Laughter]
I don't know because that's because you
know bears are masculine well I will
take Bears over a bunch of hungry people
I honestly and this at this point in my
life I'd rather not face a bear so I'm
not going to say that what I was going
to say which is I'd rather face a bear
then I'd rather not face a bear but I
just you know some life that's life
there was a story recently have a dude
who just fought a bear
we fought a bear off with his bare hands
with his bare hands something happened I
can't remember and there was like a bear
came and he had to fight it for his
family and then he won dude yeah
bears are crazy man yeah check out
Grizzly Man and have you guys seen
Grizzly Man
no it's a documentary this guy went into
the woods he was obsessed with bears and
they thought well I think there's
something wrong with this guy but he
went with his girlfriend and lived with
the Bears you know and then they said
okay you can live with bears I guess
don't do it but I guess but not when
they're not when they're hungry not when
they're getting just out of hibernation
yeah but he was like no they're my
friends it's a Werner Herzog movie dude
and you get the audio of him screaming
why would he think that I don't know
it's like it's like he had a death wish
you hear his girlfriend screaming fight
back fight back on the audio and it's
like he was just I don't know there's no
video of it the cap the lens cap was on
when it got recorded thank goodness and
then what happened to the his his was it
wife she was then killed by the bear as
well she didn't run no I don't know but
I mean I guess they were out in the
middle of the woods there's really
nowhere to run to I don't to be honest I
don't know maybe they would have both
had death wish it's a weird thing to be
doing hanging out with bears when
they're hungry I'm just imagining these
two hippies being like yo like the Bears
are my friends man that's what it was
the Bears are spawning the guy like yo
why are you mauling Joey what are you
doing no are you biting me now oh I'm
being eaten by a bear rather I try to be
too insensitive because I think he has
family and stuff but like he is
screaming like stop oh
you hear it it's so weird
as he's being torn open yeah it's
horrific the bear is just like for lunch
yeah yeah all right let's go to super
chats my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and uh did I say smash that like button
oh God head over to timcast.com we're
gonna have that members only show coming
up at 11 p.m will be fun spicy and not
so family friendly let's read what we
got here
all right Matthew reckamp says Tim if
you haven't watched 2000 mules yet then
what about a watch along in the members
only section two birds one stone that's
a really good idea I'm not for real I'll
I'll reach out to Dinesh maybe he would
want to come and we could do a thing
where we do like uh what was it Mystery
Science Theater 3000 yes yeah where
they're like they're watching it at the
same time making fun of it so we we
could do so I would totally be down to
do that make a make a members only thing
of like our initial reaction to watching
it all and then we could do that thing
where we have everybody sitting around
and then like the screen changes showing
like Tim cast and then we have the thing
playing in the middle maybe maybe Dinesh
would be down for that that'd be great
and then that's an interesting idea
because that's because then we get you
get our initial reaction to it right
away awesome and that'd be really cool
at the very least I'll ask for his
permission because I know a lot of
people are pirating it but if he was
cool with us doing something like that
yeah I don't know though it's like a
members only thing for us to make like
we make money off of it but it's like
his movie so maybe we could pay him
something or we could put it up for free
on website just be one of those
well I don't know if he wants us to give
away his movie for free yeah
well we'll talk to him about it it's
good though like our commentary will
ruin the movie so you know I will not be
as enjoyable
by its own well maybe we can work
something out with him and maybe it
wouldn't necessarily be a website thing
maybe it's a special thing that we cross
do it so you know because I don't want
to I don't take money away from his
project that he spent money producing
you know what I mean or make money off
of his work yeah that's not fair but but
it is a good idea to do a like a a
commentary like watch along
that'd be great
rude says have you guys considered
making gaming PCs or consoles to compete
with Microsoft and the like that is a
that is a very odd question I've never
thought about entering the micro
processing development that sounds like
a very difficult and Technical feel
industry to just decide to enter yeah
well I have thought about it and there's
there's a lot of competitors already in
there I don't know I mean it seems like
the smarter thing if you even think
about it would be to license the timcast
brand to exist why don't we why don't we
get some raspberry raspberry pies and
then run the new game on it and just
duct tape a bunch of Raspberry Pi's
together
the game we are making can be pre-loaded
onto a small device that people just
plug in their TV and have the game yeah
it'd be kind of cool we could do that
physical thing you could play cross
promote with like Alienware or whatever
the Tim cast Alienware yeah I've been
thinking about doing that for the
software we're developing with the
charity is get a Raspberry Pi pre-loaded
with that if it was pre-loaded with a
game too that might be kind of
interesting although many it's Overkill
all right Jay yeah says Ian's head is
full of graphene literally okay well
well sure we we did integrate Ian's
brain with graphene so that the the
neurons could connect and it would
transmit electricity much much better
but I don't remember that part yeah he
forgot but I guess it's true he got
drunk and forgot
I've had graphene on the brain we were
talking about building computers just
now I'm like no but we could build
microprocessors with graphene conductors
and I just didn't want to you know drag
you through it Daniel trinka says Tim
consider a bookstore on your website
where guests can list their books maybe
a one percent listing fee to you or
something good for them good for you
good idea that is also a strange idea
but it's good I mean yeah I like it it's
kind of weird because uh we're we're uh
we haven't we just finished uh the song
bright eyes it's it's completely done
and we're working on the music video
and we're trying to figure out how do we
brand music and then I just I was
thinking like we're doing a bunch of
crazy stuff this year in terms of
production short film documentaries
music videos music production and then I
was just like as is there any other
company that does all of this stuff like
that does
too much
you know
yeah that's too much too much is a
problem different brands for different
different things is important I just
mean like how come nobody does this you
know like where's Joe Rogan's rap album
that'd be awesome he'd be great I don't
know we gotta make it I guess you know
we're like what about a video game like
I just
you know I Joe's the easy example
because he's he's so wealthy and in the
cultural space I just wonder I shouldn't
single him out there are a lot of ultra
wealthy people I know who make way more
money than I do and I just like why
don't they do anything with it I always
ask that like Sheamus for instance you
know I make an insane amount of money
YouTube cartoons dude those pay the
bills if you want to get insanely
wealthy draw a couple pictures put them
online yeah no but but for real like any
one of these ultra wealthy people you
know why aren't they doing more stuff
the honest answer is because they don't
have the brain for it it's not personal
most people don't have the the cognitive
ability or desire to to make themselves
that busy with these that many different
thought processes because people require
also once you're that once you have that
kind of money you don't need to do
anything well it's like Tim talks about
if you're good at one thing it doesn't
mean you're good at a lot of different
things like I feel like maybe a lot of
different talents and they're also
worried about social respectability so
they don't want to do things baby you
know maybe maybe this is why I'm accused
of being on Adderall um I get all these
lefties like Tim must be on Adderall
it's like no I don't even drink I don't
do any other stuff but you know I I
don't know I just wanna we got music
coming out we got a video game coming
out we've got so much stuff that we're
trying to just crank out and expand upon
but but you know what I mean to say is
it's like weird and eclectic like
obviously some people start companies
and they make those companies the best
and the biggest the possible thing they
could be but this is a weird company
like we have our Flagship product is a
culture political podcast and then we
make video games and and music music
yeah it's normal whatever all right I'm
cool with it yeah and I guess you're
broke don't fix it we're gonna make a
video game console in a bookstore next
that's a good idea
the bookstore actually is a good idea
yeah if we made a Marketplace
and people it's like an alter like it's
a non-silicon Valley Marketplace like
why not Mike Lindell may go make an
Amazon you know let people list their
products and sell them through a portal
so people don't use Amazon
all right
Sharon sweet says health insurance
companies are looking to cover abortion
travel expenses for employees how do you
as a business owner feel about having to
pay extra for health coverage to cover
this
so here's the thing that people don't
realize
in in some states and it might be
Federal maybe you know this you can't
actually offer benefits until you reach
a certain size
so we were like you know we're at Tim
cast our Communists so we're gonna you
know do great benefits and then we're
like oh you can't do that
I mean you have to join up with like a
peo I mean I was able to do it like just
two or three employees but you have to
like there's like particular Services
you have to use to get access to it
what's the CEO I forget I don't know
what exactly the acronym is but their
companies the company's called TriNet
and the way it works is it's like they
do this for startups right like they
give basically it's like you have if
you're a startup with only a few
employees but you want to offer
competitive benefit packages then it's
like you effectively are all part of
this massive company for the purposes of
benefits and they handle your payroll
and your benefits peo is professional
employer organization yeah so that's a
company that handles other companies
just gives them a leg okay thank you
gives them the legal recourse to do
bigger stuff yeah functionality so let's
read some more the Gaelic bat says
Sheamus yesterday you said that there is
no sin too great that can't uh can't
forgiven by the sacrifice of Jesus I'm
curious does that mean you believe Satan
could be forgiven for his sins it's an
interesting question so my understanding
of this is that Satan exists
in I mean he's spiritual right he
doesn't have a corporeal form and so
just by the very nature of how angels
exist the decision they made is
permanent so he's fixed in that decision
like by his nature he will not be sorry
for what his decision was ever
all right let's read some more I can see
how that's like Satan is a is a is a
function and that different people's
Spirit can become part of that function
at different times but that function
will remain
all right
bino says Federal oil regulator worked
in Alaska from 14 to 18 in Cook Inlet as
of 18 there was little interest in those
leases Cook Inlet wasn't viewed as
lucrative by industry plus State
regulars Regulators were over
overbearing interesting I'm not I'm not
surprised like I really don't I think
it's it's weird like normally when it
comes to Biden screwing up oil and gas
leases you think okay that's just the
Biden Administration being dumb and
environmentalist it's like but I
honestly think that right now this is
probably the one time that if they're
actually deciding to cancel an oil and
gas lease it's there's probably a decent
reason for it you know because they
really really want the oil price to come
down they really do all right Samuel
Eddie says Tim's time travel
Misadventures Tim goes to the Future and
sees that it's really cool so he brings
Ian with him for the next trip but it
becomes a dystopia involves an older
version of Tim who sounds like Alex
Jones do you understand the implications
of what you said
when a person travels from their time to
the future the future they're they're in
has no influence from them because they
removed themselves from the timeline to
jump forward so if I go to the Future
and everything's really cool it means
that
in fact without me the future ended up
being really cool if I then go back and
take Ian to the Future into dystopia
that would literally mean Ian made the
future cool because without his
influence in the timeline the future to
just don't like this movie let's
definitely do that man we need to uh we
did a phone call because we're we're
preparing the music video for the new
song we did and uh like some of the best
producers it's going to be legit I was
talking to Robbie Starbucks one of the
best of the best because he used to do
music videos and I'm just like we need
to get in the short film train because I
really I really really want to do a
short film a short film about the legend
of gellert's grave you've told me about
this one yeah we've talked about it
before do you guys have to look into it
do you have a elevator elevator pitch
for it short version is old dude from
Wales back in like the 1100s or whatever
goes out to do his daily deeds and
leaves his son and his dog back at the
cabin when he returns from his daily
Deeds he sees this house has been
ransacked everything's flipped over and
he sees his son's crib is flipped over
and covered in blood then he sees his
dog Gellert walk over wagging his tail
with blood all over his mouth
and so you know seeing that believing
his dog just killed his son he draws his
sword and thrusts it straight into the
side of his dog Geller killing it
instantly and with gallard's dying well
being let out all of a sudden he hears a
baby crying and he rushes over to the
the the crib that was flipped over and
he he flips it and there's his son
perfectly safe lying next to a wolf who
had been killed by his faithful hound
and they say from that day Prince Lila
never smiled again
one of the most brutal stories he killed
the dog who saved his son's life because
he didn't even think about it so I was
like I would love to make a short film
about that it's only a couple minutes
long and it'll just be like the most
brutal short film ever you just gave
away the ending though man
if we titled it the legend of God's
great people would know exactly
Dillard's grave too gellert's back
Gellar at pet cemetery do your own twist
on it yeah Gallery part two he
accidentally buried Gallard at pet
cemetery and got returns from Revenge
the army of other dog ghosts you
betrayed me
all right where where were we
rylo says does will still support
compulsory coveted vaccination correct
me if he never did what is his stance on
abortion dumb or evil goes as follows if
you repeatedly if you got get repeatedly
punched in the face it doesn't matter
why your duty is to fight but okay uh no
I don't think I was ever for compulsory
vaccination
um
um I was generally broadly like
pro-vaccine in the sense that like I
thought they were a good thing and seems
like the evidence was that they worked
but I don't think I was pro-mandate I
think I was very consistent on that
um so I'd like to find somebody if you
can find a tweet saying different go for
it but I'm pretty sure I was pro-vaccine
anti-mandate from like the get-go
um what about your thoughts on abortion
as for abortion I think like I'm
anti-roe versus Wade I guess I'm
probably like
I would consider myself fairly moderate
like probably first trimester is okay
after that I would ban it
I think viability anything beyond
viability is psychotic
yeah like the baby can live but you've
decided for some reason to not let it I
don't know yeah no I I have the same
vote I I kind of like I'm not personally
religious so I just kind of like see you
know I think I see it as essentially a
balance of like interest like it is a
profound there's a profound liberty
interest at stake like the right yeah
and and I think that that interest tilts
more and more towards the child as like
and away from the woman as as pregnancy
goes on and so I think the thing Sheamus
gets wrong there's nothing
I'm correct I'm sorry the thing you guys
get wrong now the thing Sheamus gets
wrong is you you can't be absolutely
pro-life because you're ignoring our
blood quota to molec
no but like that's you know people are
if people are asking like I'm you know
there's a reason like I'm anti-pro
versus Wade and also I don't have like
you know
I don't expect my view to take hold in
conservatism right like just because
like this is what I personally think
does not mean I I think that I think the
left's barbaric and and I'd much rather
be they tried they tried just passing a
bill that would have given abortion up
to nine months
and what they do is this this
manipulation where they say for the
health of the mother
it's like if that was the case you would
say at you would say and every measure
must be taken to protect the life of the
child as well like if a pregnancy must
be ended at nine months to save the
mother you're just basically having a
delivery of the baby right I don't know
it's like but they're like no you can
abort it like well that's just killing
the baby at nine months it's barbaric
like second trimester abortion late
second trimester abortions that are
barbaric uh and they should be illegal
like that's just and that's not even
getting of the question now like I think
it gets true you know what the arguments
I don't like and I've talked about this
before are sort of the like the simple
syllogisms of like abortion is murder
therefore murder is a life because I
actually think like there's there's sort
of an intrinsic problem of you know if
you really are going to make the
argument that abortion is murder then
you must punish to me it's like to be
con that to go if you're gonna insist on
that logical consistency then you have
to insist on The Logical consistency of
the punishment which means women are
accessories and need to be banished
pretty severely yeah like which I which
I don't think is okay and so I kind of
get to the point that yeah I think I
think but you I mean so if someone kills
a pregnant woman they are charged with
not every double homicide and that's
true not everywhere yeah like someone
else killing a child is is going to face
a legal consequence why would someone
killing their own child not face at
least I I I think yeah the uh the the
the anti-abortion crowd typically
shows there is a distinction between an
abortion and the killing of a baby yeah
if there was a story about big buildings
where they literally brought babies in
and just killed them you'd have people
surrounding it smashing the windows and
you'd be going so there's something
there's something there's a difference
in the moral quality of the act right
there's a fun like versus like an
abortion versus walking out to someone
and shooting them in the street and no
matter and that's why I don't like the
syllogism argument because like you and
because I think that the pro-life Lobby
intrinsically does know that there's a
difference because they don't argue for
punishment in the same way
I want to make sure possible but we'll
talk maybe in the after show I actually
have to leave I'm sorry oh my baby come
on who he had is
I'll make funny argument when you're
gone
Joseph Wilkinson says Tim your theory on
fathers aborting their financial Duty
doesn't go far enough if a woman aborts
the child against the father's will she
should be forced to compensate the
father in some way how do you wake up
for that
how do you what how do you make up for
the abortion of a child that the father
didn't want to be aborted it's horrible
uh what's the fair market value of a
human baby boy
she got paid 25 Grand Prime no I'm
kidding all right uh butter Warriors
says make mummy milkers great again okay
yes Bill Hughes says before Similac
mothers made their own baby formula now
we're talking it was like milk wasn't it
right it was a crazy hack like cow milk
it was uh usually evaporated milk or
dried milk and a lot of times baby
didn't get babies and get all the
nutrients they needed they would
literally just take powdered milk and
Caro syrup frosting there you go perfect
you can put frosting in one of those
cake things and the baby can just eat
that yeah what about mashed babies need
sugar right
peas do they mashed peas that was my
favorite food as a kid formula honey
because babies uh yeah for honey perfect
yeah yeah don't give your baby honey
back in a thousand over here um yeah
babies can eat solid food until they're
like one year old so you can't beat them
a lot of stuff that's why formula is so
important avocados I do agree with your
point earlier Lydia that that formula
nice session with formula is like a
pharmacological thing that's kind of
what it's like to me a nice medium rare
rib eye yeah yeah your boy's gonna be
big and strong I love it at what age can
a baby have a nice medium rare steak
three three three years old probably
it's poor children I know it's tough oh
man
all right what is it Joseph says what's
your take on the stock market will
curious
um I take on the stock market I mean I
think like a lot of the sort of big
growth stocks that had price earnings
ratios that went wild or taking a
beating like Tesla's taking a beating
for example you know they're still at a
99 price earnings ratio uh like was it
AMC and GameStop went up or something
yeah all the all the sort of meme stuff
and all the like growth like you know it
cool its stocks are taking a beating a
lot of the normal companies aren't
taking as much of a beating like I'm
pretty sure like I was looking at splv
which is like my index of you know the
boring Coke and McDonald's or whatever
and they're all you know they're down a
little but they're all doing fine I
think
um you know we're pro we probably are in
for some sort of recession because we
got a lot of inflation out there and to
stop that you need interest rates to go
up and so that'll create some Havoc but
that doesn't mean that like long term I
think it's not the long-term collapse of
the American economy is not going to
happen right like as a result of this a
short recession
um yeah I noticed the Terra Luna
cryptocurrency I don't know if you guys
have been following this but it was
worth like eighty dollars a couple weeks
ago it's worth six ten thousandths of a
cent now it crashed ninety nine point
nine nine nine nine nine percent oh it's
like two days buy the dip bro so
it was one I almost bought it when it
was at one cent I would have lost like a
thousand percent of my money
um it's one crypto that happens so like
you're saying a total Market collapse
doesn't look like it's gonna happen
they're gonna be crashing specific types
of currencies speculative events buying
back speculative assets are the ones
that are going to suffer right either
crypto or Equity right one of you know
that's that's what that's what's
struggles in a recession you know my
thing is I I I don't have crypto because
I'm like I'm gonna make a lot of money
off this ooh yeah utility personally we
talked a little bit about it before the
show I I I bought in crypto is a digital
asset you know and the value can
fluctuate dramatically but it is it is
it's a digital store of value I'm not
looking for it to reach ten thousand
percent and make a million dollars
overnight I bought in Bitcoin a long
long time ago and there
you know it jumped up to 60 000 and I
went wow well I'm not going to sell
because that's not why I bought it and
then it falls down to 30 and I was like
huh well I don't care I didn't buy it to
sell it then it goes up to 50 again and
I'm like I don't even check the price
it's that's not why I got it mulecoin
just hit 2 000. oh yeah okay let's read
some more Ry Lyon says I was a director
at a multinational that started
belittling and discriminating against
white men I asked them to end the
policies and they said no so I let them
know it's why I left great decision good
for you man good for you you know we had
Daryl Davis on last week and I think a
lot of people were disappointed to
discover that he was a racial
identitarian they assumed the story of
the man who de-radicalized klansmen was
that he told them not to be racist when
in fact he actually met them and said
race is the the you know determinant
factor and policy and should be agree
with me instead on my racial
identitarianism and they said yes so it
wasn't that this guy de-radicalized
people from racial legendarianism they
maintained their racial identitarianism
just
their position moved a little to the
left I suppose I mean that kind of
changes the story a lot it might be I
don't know because I wasn't there when
he was doing it so I don't know exactly
the conversations it might be that he's
just kind of a chill dude and it's like
yeah I like Daryl I do and I if he says
stuff I don't agree with like I kind of
want to talk to him because he listens
it may be that he got radicalized in the
past few years with the critical race
Theory stuff yeah so when I told him the
definition of critical race Theory asked
for the book he just refused like no I
don't believe it he's like that's that's
not what it is I've heard Kimberly
Crenshaw says and then you also have
Derek Bell who um I could be wrong but
I'm pretty sure he praised Plessy versus
Ferguson and said that you know
Democrats never should have I'm sorry
that the black community never should
have pushed against it so they want it
separate but equal that's the critical
race Theory that's what they want well
let's read some more
the trooper says hey Tim long time fan
on your point of influencers versus Blue
Collar jobs I am a fire proofer for
construction sites and all I do is mask
windows and walls from overspray and
pull hoses all day and I get 25 an hour
not bad cash for low skilled labor keep
rocking dude but it's like really
important I mean you know good for you
fire proofing is I mean like good for
you yeah good for you like that's a
virtuous thing to be doing good for you
rain B says Tim a medical I am a medical
microbiologist and that's what I wanted
since I was young my little siblings
could care less and want to get money
with no work and worshiped without work
though I'm one of the grads who has
loans but I work my ass off well glad to
hear it man you know I think people
should pursue their passions and um do
their best to be good at it but also be
realistic too because sometimes people
are passionate about folklore and
mythology and it's really cool if you
know a lot and you could be hired as a
movie consultant you know they're like
hey we want to do a movie it's fantasy
and we want to have you know these gods
and these ancient creatures and they're
going to need someone who's an expert on
that but I really don't think that's
going to be like a consistent job if
there's an expert out there I'd like to
know when the comet struck North America
13 000 years ago 12 800 have caused the
flood that sunk Atlantis how long
between when the comet was in the sky
and they saw it and when it connected
how long was that and who was running
Atlantis and who was running Atlantis at
that time and where did the atlanteans I
really want to know how long they saw
that thing before it hit and how how
long the society had to prepare if they
even knew what it was
all right it was Joe Biden he's an old
guy
psycho Dragon says psycho Dragon Studios
is making an art an arpg I'm a medically
retired vet making a triple A level game
mostly solo Dev on ue4 where are we we
aren't Rich busy grinding away the
character in my profile is one of my
NPCs my team is anti-woke on commission
cool good luck yeah absolutely
Corey the Merrell says for mules you
could release an audio commentary
viewers are meant to play with the movie
also please consider watching the anime
legend of the galactic heroes it's
available on an H uh hid live
that's a really good idea we could do it
and we won't show the documentary we
will say
we're going to show the timestamp of the
documentary so you know where our
commentary is in the film so you can
easily synchronize it yourself and then
if you buy the film you can hear our
commentary along with it yeah and then
you can turn the volume down you can do
your own levels that's a good idea
yeah
the only issue I suppose is there might
be periods where we would want to pause
things but we could I guess just leave
the room and the time stamp stops I
think we'll have to commit to letting it
run and just if you've got to go go and
come back I mean pause it to make a
point to be like hold on hold on pause
he just said this the guys did you hear
that and let's look that up
I don't know maybe maybe we'll do a deep
dive or something we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out that'd be really
cool
Samuel Hess says Hey will not sure if
the milk thing was slightly a joke but I
had major uh colic as a baby and my mom
couldn't make breast milk or anything on
the Shelf work so my parents used goat
milk worked great and as a 36 year old
gay man doing great
it works for some people I'm not gonna
say like goat milk doesn't work for
anybody I'm just saying like they're you
know there are kids who really do need
the formula like there's and so and
those are the kids who are really
struggling right now right even with
this Colonel baby formula shorts most
people can find Formula that works check
this out
always Point North says I live in
California work as a ready mix driver
there's also a cement powder shortage
what cement I think a general supply
chain problems everywhere right like I
mean I think baby short formula is
particularly impacted because of that
that plant shutdown but there's there's
problems everywhere
tricky says I work for TriNet would
suggest a different company because
TriNet has been going more and more woke
in the past few years I.E Dei training
so bad I'm thinking of looking for
another job after seven plus years
fair enough but trying net is just an
example of a company in the space yeah
of peos yeah Andrew Barnes says dark is
a radical he's defining systemic and not
systematic racism there's a difference
oh is he referring to another Super Chat
Tyler prices Ian it was multiple impacts
over 22 years yeah yeah I think it was
over 800 years there were two bouts of
like there was a Oh 22-year collisions
that's insane but what I want to know is
the first the one that actually caused
the flood itself uh what was that how
long I mean obviously it's a big
question I don't know if historians have
figured it out yet
all right they got nailed twice in 800
years another 800 years later it came
back and that's why the Egyptians have
all these hieroglyphs of pointing at
comets because they're like hey guys in
the future look out get ready warning
watch out
oh what's this we have a super chat from
someone named the real Hydro who says
Tim you and Joel both had the same guest
Daryl Davis while on your show Daryl
exposed himself on Joe he was put on a
pedestal Joe is clueless
that's why I wonder if this is that
Daryl's been radicalized more recently
because we had him at an event and none
of this stuff came up before like I
talked to him and he was not talking
about any of that stuff maybe no one's
ever given the opportunity to actually
talk about those issues or challenge
those issues and hear what he thought
about them yeah we started talking about
reparations it got kind of derailed into
money but he was pretty clear like he
doesn't think it has to be a money thing
it just would figure out a way to repair
the system
I think it was all wrong anyway all
right guys we're going to go over that
member segment so make sure you smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show if you really do
like it it helps and if you become a
member at timcast.com you're not only
supporting our journalists you're not
only getting access to our members
content but you're supporting
alternatives to Big Tech infrastructure
and we're not just stopping by utilizing
the services we are actively building
more right now and I can't wait to
announce it but we gotta wait until we
do it before we announce it and you know
some people are asking about like the
comment section
infrastructure questions that will be
answered once we fully implement it and
it's like it's it's it's politics man
you know people are trying to get us
shut down so once we get these
infrastructure changes made we can we
can do a lot you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast will do you want to shout
anything out yeah just right now follow
me on Twitter at Will Chamberlain at
Will Chamberlain
so go over to Freedom Tunes we just
released a video today called bro v Wade
I think you guys are really going to
enjoy it I really was said that the
Egyptians had a hieroglyph of them
pointing at a comment I remember seeing
it when I was younger it could have been
I'm looking into it now because I
haven't looked in a long time so maybe
maybe the Egyptians didn't have that I
got to really source that before I
emphatically drive it home have a nice
evening guys see you next time I want to
thank will so much for coming this
evening and bringing his lovely wife and
beautiful baby it's very fun to see both
of them again for sure the baby for the
first time which is really neat you guys
may follow me on twitterminds.com at
Sarah patchlitz as well sourpachlets.me
we will see you all at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys